Elon Musk is now on the board of
directors over at Twitter wow he's
promising significant changes and
improvements some people think it's a
smoke screen Elon Musk comes out and
says who wants an edit button and then
Twitter comes out like actually we
tweeted we are working on an edit button
a week ago so Elon actually didn't do
anything however many people said Elon
bring back Donald Trump
and Twitter said no no we're not going
to be bringing back Donald Trump some
people are concerned that this is just a
pump and dump Elon buys up nine percent
of the company and then the stock price
skyrockets I think he's already up
somewhere around like 750 million
dollars towards his investment and then
he waits a little bit people start
building uh faith in the platform that's
going to fix things then he sells off
his stock and jumps yet I'm not entirely
convinced though because apparently Elon
actually called The Babylon B ask them
about their suspension and then said I
might need to buy Twitter so I think
Elon will try to make some positive
changes it probably won't be that much
though I can't imagine him bringing back
Alex Jones or anyone else and apparently
Twitter's saying it's not going to
happen so we'll talk about that but
we've got some really really crazy News
Oklahoma
has effectively banned abortion outright
except I think only in the instance of
the life of the mother Colorado did the
opposite and basically is allowing
unfettered abortion up to the point of
birth I believe right is that up to the
point of birth there were no
restrictions no restrictions in the law
and so uh wow we definitely got that
that's going to be huge so we'll talk
about that plus we got a billionaire
saying the end is nigh or he's just
saying inflation is going to get really
really bad and you can blame Joe Biden
Joe Biden is going to be extending the
uh student loan relief freezing payments
AOC is saying just cancel it AOC is also
embroiled in a scandal where apparently
her campaign was funneling a million
dollars to two packs and not documenting
what they were doing in the FEC
dismissed the complaint waited a month
and then released the information saying
oh yeah the complaint was correct though
AOC was apparently I'll be careful to
describe what she was doing but um
funneling money to other uh
organizations without tracking it which
you know I guess you can call dark money
or as some have said illegal uh the
organization that sued said that there
have been way uh there have been many
other people that have been have charges
against them for way less than what AOC
did so we'll talk about all of that
joining us today is ilad aliyahu would
you like to introduce yourself a lot
what's up everybody Tim thank you so
much for having me on uh my name is alad
aliyahu I'm a field reporter I
contribute for timcast I'm also on
Instagram YouTube I cover protests civil
unrest political rallies Tim thank you
for having me on absolutely you've been
you've actually covered Trump rallies
protests for us at timcast.com on the
ground so you've actually got to talk to
progressives and and conservatives and
get the full view on the ground awesome
it's been I've been at the Trump rally
in Georgia I was at a trump rally in
Arizona I was in one in South Carolina
it's super interesting to see how the
Trump rallies differ now from when they
were during the presidential they're a
little bit more lackluster now it's
interesting too to see Trump endorsing
only people who say the election was
stolen and things like that so it's
really interesting to see the dividing
line play out at these Trump rallies I'm
going to be at another Trump rally this
weekend I believe it is in North
Carolina thanks to Tim oh yeah right on
cool we also got Libby hi hey Tim how's
it going who are you I'm Libby Emmons
I'm the editor-in-chief of the
post-millennial and I love coming on the
show you can find me on Twitter at Libby
Emmons we have like a bunch of stories
from the post-millennial for that
because we're awesome yeah yeah the the
one I like a lot of great stuff today
Andy no captured a whole bunch of
Twitter employees freaking out that was
amazing yeah oh no I tweeted that uh
everybody at Twitter now works for the
whims of Elon Musk he's the he's he owns
nine percent so every single time that
woke Progressive clicks that button or
submits that that form or helps
facilitate Twitter in any way they are
putting money in the pocket of Elon Musk
and it was amazing you see um the sub
stack vice president oh yeah yeah
tweeted out that they're hiring and that
uh disgruntled triggered Twitter
employees need not apply yep
we also got Sheamus yes I am here
Sheamus Coughlin of Freedom Tunes I
create animated political cartoons I
upload a new one every single Thursday
sometimes on Tuesdays and I'm happy to
do the show also I love the idea of
these Twitter employees being like you
know we can't just let some powerful
Tech billionaire decide what can be said
on the internet this is ridiculous this
is very unfair someone needs to look
into stopping this they're a little too
little too late I think I am amused by
the idea of these Twitter people having
a very bad day but hopefully Elon
actually makes positive improvements I'm
also here I'm Sarah patchlitz I'm
producing in the corner before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com and become a member to help
support our work as a member you will
keep all of our journalists gainfully
employed as they write articles all day
every day we have a story here about
some apparently a fox bit a Democrat so
I hope they get their rabies shots it's
kind of scary but you'll also get access
to exclusive episodes of this show
Monday through Thursday at 8pm so
subscribe become a member we're gonna
have one of those episodes up tonight
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and share the
show right now wherever you can
Grassroots marketing is the only way we
uh we grow the show we don't do big ad
buys and it's very difficult to compete
with the corrupt mainstream media when
they're getting propped up by YouTube
but with your help we can do better so
we really really do appreciate it now
let's get into that first story from the
Daily Mail bad news Twitter says as it
will not reinstate Trump despite Elon
Musk vowing significant change to woke
platform after taking a board seat with
nine percent stake but this also means
it's that's there's going to be no Alex
Jones no Milo yiannopoulos Twitter said
it has no plans to reverse any policy
decisions and it's com and is committed
to impartiality in the development and
enforcement of its policies and rules
now that being said
okay they say our policy decisions are
not determined by the board of board or
shareholders and we have no plans to
reverse any policy decisions as always
our board plays an important advisory
and feedback role across the entirety of
our service our day-to-day operations
and decisions are made by Twitter
management and its employees
they can say that but I'm not entirely
convinced because I do think with a 9.2
percent share Elon Musk has substantial
weight a lot of people are pointing out
that I can't remember the guy's name
someone they said someone was it Ryan
Cohen he bought a stake in in GameStop
and then got a position on the board or
something like that I'm not entirely
sure but uh people are saying look even
though it's not a controlling share it's
not 50 it scared them enough to give
Elon what he wanted in terms of a seat
at the table and part of that
arrangement with Elon says he can't buy
in any way more than 14.9 percent of the
company so I think they're scared of a
pump and dump I think they're scared
he's gonna get too much power and I
think
Elon might actually have uh an impact on
this platform at the very least if they
listen to what the man has to say he's
going to make all of them much more
wealthy and if they don't well then they
can I mean the dudes whatever he's
touching is turning the gold right with
Tesla SpaceX and all that stuff yeah
he's doing a great job with all that's
all those things but but uh in terms
where does it even where does this go
and and I got I gotta say
everyone's really excited about Elon
buying a portion of the company then
this morning we hear that Elon is on the
board of directors does anyone really
believe is going to be substantial
substantial changes to this platform I
think everyone was looking for something
a little hopeful I think people want
things to be better on Twitter where you
can say true things and not be banned
for it um I don't know that Elon Musk is
going to provide that kind of change
that he would have the power to do so
um I think like a what is it like Morgan
Stanley also owns 9.2 percent is it 9.2
I think no no I think he's the largest
he is the largest are you sure because I
was looking at it the other day and they
had a 9.2 share so BlackRock owned
something like 6.2 7.2 I could be wrong
I don't know I mean I did it last night
I took a look at it but I don't know how
to find it fast yeah but yeah I know
that
um but they haven't they probably
haven't affected any substantial change
um but Elon Musk obviously made this Buy
in order to affect change I like Elon
Musk so that's the question is does he
have the power to do it does he have the
wherewithal to do will he be allowed to
do it three billion dollar 2.89 billion
dollar purchase to make this move you
know I like Elon Musk I don't know if
anything is going to happen from this
but boy is is everything just so boring
he's also had a lot of back and forth on
the platform with Jack Dorsey which I
think has been so interesting because
Dorsey the other day apologized that's
right that was really interesting I
think his perspective
um Dorsey has two percent 2.25 right two
point I don't know I had I thought it
was two but uh you know who knows but
look look it's interesting when Trump
was in office and when Trump was on
Twitter it was like being on a roller
coaster every day it was fun right and
now that he's gone it's just like every
day it's like oh look and you know they
bomb somebody again and so Elon Musk
comes in and he's like I'm gonna make
this ridiculous three billion dollar
purchase and I'm like all right
something's happening I gotta honestly
something happens I got a lot of
thoughts on this I hope this isn't just
an expensive way to make sure that he
doesn't get banned off the platform he's
yeah as long as I have almost 10 steak
they're definitely not going to ban me
off the platform but I have a lot of
thoughts on this because as we're seeing
different social media platforms emerge
and then others become old and kind of
useless I'm not sure that same thing
will happen with Twitter I see some of
these old um social media companies try
to stay relevant one way or another
Facebook by buying Instagram and doing
their new meta thing but now we're kind
of seeing how Tick Tock kind of took
them all over very quickly but at the
same time I'm ambivalent because as you
guys know Trump just started truth
social and that fell flat on its face so
if there's no way which way to go and
while he might be a better alternative
than say Jack Dorsey or Prague the
currency he's not going to be a CEO yeah
but it's he'll be like that influence
will be good there but also I think we
need to be critical of Elon Musk um I'm
extremely hawkish when it comes to China
and they just opened a bunch of
factories in China and many companies in
China at the whim of the Chinese
government and he's praised them he's
praised them also like awkwardly as well
because he also pray raises of American
values too so I don't know if he's a
businessman just trying to play into
both sides also 10 cent a Chinese
company has a five percent stake in
Tesla so there's a lot of different
loans and influence there something to
keep an eye on but better than the
alternative
the thing with truth social is it didn't
offer anything new to the concept of
social media it didn't even offer Trump
well it didn't even offer Trump yeah
what am I going to sign up for what's up
like yeah the point of Truth social was
to try to sign up and see what Trump
says and I still just get his little
statements in my email but that's the
thing about the new social media
platforms right getter and Truth social
whatever else you want to throw in there
they're not doing anything disruptive to
the industry and there needs to be a
disruptive influence for it to have any
hold like Tick Tock was did a new thing
whether you like it or not yeah no
exactly and what a lot of conservatives
have been saying is we need conservative
social media platforms that's not true
we need social media platforms that
everyone wants to use which also won't
ban conservatives and so right these
sort of Market themselves and it might
be cynical they might understand they're
actually selling a niche product to
People by giving them the hope that
it'll turn into something more but
ultimately it just gets filled with
conservatives regular people who don't
have any kind of political bench or
people on the left are still using
Twitter or Instagram and it doesn't
really get us anywhere also I don't
think these other social media
alternatives are actually free speech
platforms like they claim to be I think
it was gab but there's a couple of other
like Twitter wannabes who do have a
direction they're not I'm not a free
speech absolutist you can't have every
single thing on your feed all the time
the gore the other stuff that we don't
need to get into but these they they
call themselves Free Speech but there's
something different so everybody has
their own version of what they want to
call free speech and get us as close as
you can get but even they don't allow
docs in I agree with that but you know
we had torba here and he was like nobody
likes that you know what I mean weren't
you not even allowed to talk trash about
something I forgot the exact examples
but kind of wild gab you know their
policy is if the first amendment allows
it and then I said yeah but the First
Amendment does allow doxing and he's
like well there is an exception now
that's still an interesting point
because there was a great conversation
that happened at Tucker Carlson a couple
years ago where someone said you know
Tucker was talking about censorship and
free speech and hate speech and they
said Tucker would you allow someone on
your show to say a bunch of racial slurs
and he was like no course not he's like
exactly because you have policies for
your platform now the issue there is
while I agree we don't like racists Fox
News Tucker Carlson's show is his show
where he has a space for one guest to
come and sit down and of course he can
curate that Twitter is claiming to be
this open public forum that has actually
taken over the Town Center in that case
yeah we shouldn't all be just the
Arbiters of Truth and morality
determining who is or isn't allowed to
speak don't kill those but you wanna you
wanna grab it and just not crush it that
one it's too late for that one no well
no no I'm saying if you squish it it
stinks there's things okay so just ball
it up and throw in the trash I'll be
right back guys you got to give the
warning about the stink bugs oh yeah
yeah when you crush them I thought you
should just let them climb on King Kong
yeah ruthless I'm hawkish I was taking
that book yeah but stink bugs are going
to bomb that stink bugs don't do
anything they're funny they're just
stupid yeah they're just stink I'm just
anti-bug it's irrational it's not climb
King Kong usually we just watch them do
their thing because stink bugs are
everywhere I was I was actually sort of
distracted I saw a couple of you guys
looking and I was like I'm going to take
it out
I saw these swords around too I got a
little bit excited because if you don't
have any Firearms or I was walking
through the through the hallway in here
and a stink but I was on the wall and
saw me and what the stink bugs do as a
defensive move is just Kamikaze they
just jump to the floor and so I'm
walking and it just like falls in the
air goes and I'm just like this stupid
thing
we were talking about something
important yeah what was the last thing
you said I do think though that I mean
we're talking about uh Trump and Trump
being on platforms and Twitter says they
have no plans to put him back on but
that doesn't mean they won't at some
point can you imagine if Trump was back
on Twitter it would be really a lot of
fun would be hitting his Life Alert like
oh my goodness is Life Alert oh my God
what a fantastic day that would be could
you imagine if we got to see him
tweeting throughout this presidency did
you see what would be great would be
Trump replying to Biden's stupid things
like Biden's video last week where he
told told all American parents to affirm
their kids and gender transition and
it's just like what are you what do you
say like you don't know what that means
this is a true story when I was a little
kid I told my mom I wanted to be a
pumpkin nice she said You are My Little
Pumpkins
this is like actually a true story I was
like a little kid my mom would be like
he says he wants to be a pumpkin and
it's like yeah I was a little kid could
you imagine if they're like well all
right I guess and then just like that's
my question is like put a pumpkin over
my body why is it only gender we're
supposed to affirm you know why aren't
we supposed to affirm dinosaurs or dogs
or when the kid walks around thinking
that they're a cat or a robot my son for
a while thought maybe he was a robot
what about a superhero like why are we
not affirming kids who think they're
superheroes and believe they can fly why
aren't we affirming those kids
I do have a true story of the dangers of
this kind of affirmation when I was a
little kid there was a Nintendo game
called Mighty bomb Jack and so I took a
plastic shopping bag and put it over my
arms like a cape and started Jumping on
the Bed yelling Mighty bomb Jack and I
fell and I banged my leg on the bed post
I tried screaming and uh almost
seriously hurt myself if only see my
parents they affirmed me I have a
similar story they didn't actually this
true story when I was a little kid yeah
when I was like is it a firm or maybe a
little bit of neglect no it was like
just good for a kid a little kid was
running around doing dumb kid things
look I think that's a good thing I had a
Buzz Lightyear costume and I jumped off
my couch temping to fly when I was like
two or three and broke my ankle so
really similar instances yes yeah good
work everyone well I I thought I could
be a ballerina and so I got signed up
for ballet lessons and during a recital
I fell off a stage oh my god well I
clearly should have kept me home no that
is like you don't identify that's good
affirmation your parents should
encourage you to do arts and sports and
all that stuff yeah what they should
encourage you to do is like I don't know
take chemicals that permanently alter
your body when you're too young
um they shouldn't kill their
grandchildren before you've even had
your first sexual experiences well I
think I think it's this is particularly
simple it's
um you wouldn't give a little girl
breast implants to affirm her sexuality
you wouldn't give a little boy breast
implants either I don't understand why
they're gonna do my son once asked me
what I would say if he told me he wanted
to wear nail polish to school and I told
him that I would say absolutely not and
I and then I was like and ask me what I
would say if you were a girl and he and
I was like you would also not be allowed
to wear nail polish to school I don't
care what your sex is there's no nail
polish in school I want to talk about
Elon Musk though let's go let's jump
over to this article from the
post-millennial Twitter employees
triggered by Elon Musk buying ownership
stake and platform Elon Musk is now one
of the largest shareholders this we know
and we have a collection of tweets this
is Andy Andy Noe did all of this
reporting Cassie Nick rumbaugh a data
scientist is among the employees and
contractor is very upset saying a
prominent trans foe but buying a large
steak in Twitter is not at all funny I
think it is yeah it's very funny
big laughs I'm honestly kind of
terrified right now you see the the
reason why I I don't respect you Cassie
because you literally have nothing to
fear because Elon Musk isn't going to do
anything to you not only not I mean
we're sitting here being like I doubt
Elon will actually even get anything
done and you're like I'm terrified of
what of some guy who lives far away from
you you've never met before who's going
to do nothing I just if he's you know
I'm you know I'd be more worried about
I'm more worried about a wasp coming
through the window Yeah because
sometimes those wasps that climb through
the edge of the windows
Protestants breaking it yeah that's
right they got the gym you know they're
just getting drunk over there here we go
we've got uh Gerard Taylor says my
current sentiment stock is up yay but
what about our company culture pronouns
it's one guy they all have the pronouns
maybe he's on the board of directors
once a year he'll come in and vote on
stuff and the day-to-day operations will
be run by other people he's going to be
one guy voting on the board there he's
not gonna be able to do anything
dramatic he's going to go to the other
investment companies and say look if you
want this to make more money and you
want to fix the platform you've got to
give a little bit back you're not going
to see Trump you're not going to see
Alex Jones they're going to keep their
misgendering policies but they're going
to do little things here and there
little titty little little tidbits like
the Babylon B will get reinstated and
conservatives will be like yay and then
you know be like see look now people are
building confidence in the platform
coming back you had truth social you had
getter you have gab you have all these
platforms trying to compete parlor you
need to stop that elon's going to be
curious how you do it and very little
will change in my opinion I hate that
those are all copycats too though like I
hate that the so-called conservatives
never have new ideas it's not a fresh
type of social media it's literally here
let me copy and paste Twitter and then
have our own version of what we're going
to censor and then you know hope that
we're successful literally just steal
yes Twitter's idea and also not offer
anything at our platform that would get
regular people to want to use it yeah I
mean there's nothing there's no appeal
to these websites other than this is
where conservatives can go and what's
the point if we're only talking to
ourselves it's like there's a big
Stadium yeah that's really the
interesting thing too is why would you
migrate over to these other platforms
you know the thing with Facebook I keep
wanting to get rid of Facebook but my
whole family chat is on Facebook and so
it's like if I want to know when the
reunion is I have to stay on Facebook
and find out but I do think that it's
key to have something new like you guys
were talking about when like if you're
going to invent something new in an
existing space
um you have to have a reason for it and
none of these reasons these are like
ideological reasons that but they're not
operational or aesthetic reasons yeah
well it's hilarious because oftentimes
conservatives will look at something
that the left has completely dominated
and they'll go oh man the left created
this new thing that they then ended up
exerting disproportionate control on how
can we do that I'll Tell You by
inventing a new thing you then exert a
disproportionate amount of control and
that control can be in favor of free
speech rather than Banning left-wing
people but they completely missed the
point because as you said what we need
is innovation yeah and I think also
Zuckerberg and Dorsey probably didn't
start off as leftists I mean the default
uh as they were coming up and doing
whatever they were doing and going to
school the default was leftism so that's
that was there Zuckerberg used to talk
about why does anybody want to be on
Twitter why does anybody want to be on
Twitter for what reason do you want to
be on Twitter to hurt other people's
feelings or maybe have your feelings
hurt for
uh um news and memes yes the only reason
conservatives want to be on the platform
is because Twitter is the space where
prominent
politicians personalities journalists
are sharing ideas it's where a lot of
ideas originate the problem is the left
has no interest in conservatives or
Libertarians or post-liberals for that
matter so there's literally nothing you
gain for me on the platform other than
talking to people who already agree with
you the left can go on Twitter and say
something conservatives will see it
liberals will see it conservatives go on
the platform and say something liberals
never see it that is kind of interesting
isn't it so there's literally no benefit
to anyone associated with libertarianism
civil libertarianism like true like
liberalism not the woke garbage there's
no reason to be on the platform there's
going to be some high profile
journalists who's going to be like I
need to go on TV and cry because people
were mean to me and it's like that's
funny because like the New York the New
York Times the New York Times and MSNBC
don't talk to us about the fact that
we've been swatted seven times or had
the bomb squad call to our house me
tweeting that does nothing to affect the
corporate garbage world that I no longer
care about you don't think you have a
lot of liberals following you I do yeah
but like my point is conservatives
Libertarians moderates have no influence
with the establishment and they're not
going to on any of these platforms so
why care about being there if you can't
get your followers on other platforms
well then you've got a cultural problem
well then you'll be in an echo chamber
though because if you go on gab you're
really on Twitter is already an echo
chamber that's my point I think you get
more you have like a bigger Spectrum
than you would on gab though I wouldn't
know because I've only been on gap for a
couple of weeks but what I saw there
wasn't you know as politically diverse
or you know there's even there's more to
Twitter too than just politics and on
gab and these other other social media
platforms it feels like it's solely
focused on conservative politics and
then it's the most extreme of them too I
feel like it's the same thing that
happens once you like Redline it or not
Redline where you gerrymander a district
and you make them more red and deeper
blue then you're just going to get more
extreme candidates who are willing to
Pander harder but this is part of a
larger problem which is that
conservatives only have politics right
politics is the only sphere of our
culture in which conservatives have any
stake or any in or like any you know
ability to affect any change
conservatives don't have a stake in you
know publishing or the Arts or anywhere
else and so that's the bigger issue that
has changed I'm working on it it is
changing and you know that's interesting
and conservative Counter Culture in the
Arts I think is a movement that's about
you know that should be about Aesthetics
it should be about interesting work it
shouldn't be ideological and the work
that currently exists on the left side
of the spectrum is entirely ideological
and it's ideological at this point by
Design so what we need to do is work you
know to like have good content which I
think you know you guys are both doing
that is not political and that has and
the left is more bearing on culture yeah
the left is producing more and more
ideological garbage that people don't
because it's shitty and nobody wants to
watch it exactly well it's is
there's there's two big things happening
with with liberal arts uh I'm in a
literal sense
and it's that one there's a severe lack
of talent
um probably due to the fact that
meritocracy is out the window for these
people so when you are hiring people for
like the sake of your ideological points
you're gonna get someone who's never
done the job before has no Talent doing
it but that doesn't matter because
everyone should have an equal it should
be Equity so everyone should just do
this job it's very obvious when these
people have this ideology where it's
like take the tools from the farmer and
give it to the farm hands oh no they
don't know how to farm and then everyone
starves to death that that same
principle applies to every other
industry but the other issue is just
that when when you've got a lack of
talent but also a desire to inject
ideology which doesn't work no it makes
bad art it makes very poor work a great
example is you know the kind of garbage
I watch so
um I thought you're about to say freedom
Tunes I was like why you gotta come at
me that way she's looking right at me
she's like I have a really good example
right in front of me except for the
bouchy episodes I don't need to hear it
if you look at the Star Trek stuff it
used to be good and now I haven't
watched a lot of the new Star Trek but I
do watch red letter media talking about
it and then I sort of like dip in a
little bit do you know what the news
it's a disaster and it's all ideological
and it's like there's this affirmative
action higher uh on the new Picard and
she's terrible what do you mean
um Rafi is this one character but how is
that there's a I don't know so she's
very stupid and it's sort of impossible
to believe that she could have gotten
into Starfleet oh well I mean that's
just but that that's like a a plot
choice right about a character so it's
poorly you you could make it very poorly
sure sure the bigger issue I have is
Picard is a
um the one of the first I believe the
first follow-up to the 90s series which
is which ended with Deep Space Nine and
and since then all they've been doing is
prequels why because we are culturally
stagnant yes so that's true I'll explain
I just want to clarify everybody you
know you know I'm a big Star Trek fan
you don't got to be a Star Trek fan to
understand this in the 90s we had new
Star Trek shows they were wildly popular
Star Trek the Next Generation was one of
the most popular shows of all time it
was syndicated on three networks that's
huge after that they said what do we do
now I don't know do a prequel now a lot
of people do like Enterprise but it's a
prequel we're just like go back in time
I thought it was boring and take
existing stories where are we now
Discovery CBS a prequel Stacy Abrams is
the president Eric they're accused of
ripping off the story here's the best
part they start Picard which is uh that
is finally the 90s Star Trek gets a
sequel series and what is it about
the first season is basically member
berries remember Rika remembered Picard
member data and it's like okay yeah I'm
a big fan of all those things it's fun
to see them again what's season two
about they go back in time they're like
remember because something happened
happened in 2024 to turn Earth into a
human supremacist planet and the
fascists must be stopped and I'm like
why is Star Trek at the same time that I
live no I want to watch tonight
aliens yeah well this is what's so cool
even if you're trying to cram your world
view into something where it otherwise
doesn't belong try to come up with some
clever analogy for it instead of going
human surprise we're going to talk about
human Supremacy do you guys get it and
watching at home do you get it do you
get what we're actually talking about
it's so obnoxious are people gay on the
new Star Trek
what are there any gay people in the in
the reboot movies they made Sulu gay
like they they did a scene that didn't
need to be in the movie that was this
this is one of the issues I think take
was actually not cool with that even
though he's gay right he said make new
characters yeah so in the in the movies
they did a scene where it's like they're
coming to to port or whatever and then
Sulu runs up to a guy who's got like a
daughter and they kiss and it's just
like that did nothing for the movie I
don't care if the characters are gay
John Constantine you guys know John
Constantine is DC DC character he's they
did a movie with Keanu Reeves it wasn't
really true to the original character
he's an amazing character this character
has been bi since 1992. so he like he
has boyfriends and girlfriends and they
make and it's like a part of his
character art so when I see a show I'm
watching DC's Legends of tomorrow and
he's got like a boyfriend I'm not like
why I'm like oh I get it his motivation
is that his his boyfriend's Soul was
trapped in hell I'm like yeah I
understand that I have no issue with
that that's fine it's when they take
characters and they put things in plots
that don't make sense for the sake of of
just a virtuous segment to Their
audience like look what we did it feels
shoehorned in I feel like Chris rufo
found something that like with the
Disney one of the Disney directors
saying that they're trying to make like
50 of the characters LGBT that wasn't
just the director saying that they have
that I think on their on their like
Mission I think they have that written
down that by 2050 it would be
um and that's just not a very
interesting way to do it it's not it
doesn't make for good stories to say I'm
going to have this character with this
specific characteristics when you're
writing characters you have to like
listen to your characters you have to
invent them they have to be authentic
and real and you can't just like apply
stuff to your characters and say you
know here's my character Mary and she's
going to be all of these things and I'm
just going to make that work and shove
them into that character it has to be
real I'll tell you I'll tell you why I
think woke plot writing doesn't work you
have to understand the motivations to
feel for the story and my the example
I'll give you is when the Batman
animated series won I think the it was
the first Emmy I could be wrong for an
animated series and it was with their
episode in the origins of Mr Freeze do
you guys know this story comic book
villains used to be one dimensional I'm
going to take over the world and then in
the Batman animated series they write
the story about a scientist whose wife
is dying of a terminal disease so he
chronogenically freezes her and then
starts misappropriating corporate funds
from his job to try and find a cure when
the boss finds out he says you're
stealing my money shut it down he's like
no you'll kill Nora you can't so they
get into a fight with the security
guards the cryochemicals spray all over
them he becomes Mr Freeze his entire
motivations that his wife is dying and
he will stop at nothing to save her life
and so it's kind of sad but he's a bad
dude because he hurts people and then it
ends with him and his prison cell like
saying like oh Nora and he's holding a
snow globe and it's like miserably sad
this guy became a villain that's like
wow those motivations man when you see
these woke stories like the craft where
they put a spell on a guy to turn him
gay I'm like what is your motivation
here yeah aha let's make a jock gay and
I'm like I don't understand what that
has to do with like your motivations in
life are you just mean people like
that's lgbtq representation Tim they're
trying to tell us that that's where gay
people come from there's what they're
trying to say in in legends of Tomorrow
John Constantine he's this uh he's like
a Exorcist he has a boyfriend his
boyfriend Saul gets damned to hell and
this makes him distraught I'm like I
understand that motivation I don't you
know have attraction to dudes but I can
understand caring about someone I
understand that motivation a lot of
these woke shows are motivated by weird
things like when um Brie Larson and
Captain Marvel steals the clothing of
the guy on the motorcycle I'm like what
was the purpose of that plot point was
it to show us that she like Bree is just
a bad person and that feminists are mean
like I don't like why why in the stories
like she's gonna steal a guy's clothes
and steal his motorcycle from him and I
I've said this before a number of times
but it's really important whenever
you're making anything and this holds
true for what we're doing with freedom
Tunes as well even though we're talking
about politics when I'm making something
I'm not thinking what point can I get
across what's the agenda here that's
very rarely the case it's usually just
looking at a situation and saying what
do I think is funny and obviously
because I am a conservative person the
things that I'm going to think are
funnier probably things other
conservative people are going to think
is funny when they look at the issue or
are funny when they look at the issue if
you go into it going I desperately need
the audience to know every single piece
of my political worldview related to
this issue you're just going to make
garbage it's going to be really really
boring it's someone someone super
chatted us and we'll go back in the
Super Chat section and read through it
but I do want to point out a bit of what
your point was and this is from
I can't trust an alarm or whatever but
he was saying that uh before the Empire
before the dark days this is an uh
another uh who tweeted this um I'm sorry
not tweeted who posted it they Eddie he
was saying before the Empire before the
dark days all of these social media
platforms were conservative and that's
mostly true remember remember when um
Phil
um Phil DeFranco he hosted Gary Johnson
on his show libertarian mike.com which
went woke originally was all about
libertarianism and Ron Paul interesting
Twitter was I remember that Donald Trump
and conservatives and it was dominated
the Twitter was a lot of journalists who
are you know talking and a lot of news
organizations getting no traction and
then conservatives were generating
massive attention and engagement now all
these platforms were taken over by the
far left kicked out all the people on
the right and they become stagnant dry
boring and broken well because they're
only interested in their ideological
perspective they're not interested in
new ideas they're interested in
entrenching and enforcing the existing
ones it's so troubling that all these
companies have become ideological in One
Direction or another because then it
also leads other companies to also want
to become ideological so now we have
Disney trying to inject whatever liberal
values but then we have the daily wire
who you know is a news a news company
right they hire journalists they make
news podcasts but they're also getting
in the kids entertainment business I'm
not sure if they're going to inject any
values in their content but it just
sucks that every company now has
developed a political angle one way or
another because I don't know if that's
what the market has to Bear we force it
onto these companies well what the the
daily wire realized that as Andrew
Breitbart said politics is Downstream
from culture and for too long
conservatives have neglected to be
producing any kind of cultural content
typically conservatives just complain
about stuff and then they're content to
complain about it as it's like imagine
being in the Titanic and complaining
that it's sinking and then not doing
anything to like save yourself save
others or stop the sinking from
happening and that's what it was for a
very very long time the daily wire is
like let's start baling water or at
least build a life raft so their content
probably will have values in it but it's
going to be value as we recognize and
probably like well and the values should
come into the work in an organic fashion
exactly as well I mean that's what it
should be like I remember this was years
ago now but I was commissioned to write
a play for the Williamstown theater
Festival and
um I was working with a director who was
older and she was single and she was
trying to decide if she should have a
child even though she didn't have a
partner and so we were talking about
this and I was like okay well we you
know this is what she wanted to do a
play about I was like okay cool so we
started digging into it and very very
organically the take of the play started
to be
uh no you probably shouldn't have a
child without you know a family
structure without not intentionally you
probably should not intentionally create
a fatherless child
um you know on purpose just to satisfy
your own pleasure at this point and that
was a very organic perspective and uh it
ended up
not getting produced and getting me into
a lot of trouble and I didn't stay at
the festival very long yeah but it
wasn't or it wasn't I would I didn't go
into it saying I want to write a play
about the Integrity of the family unit
that's just sort of what happened was I
wrote a play that was about taking
responsibility for your reproductive
material you know yeah no absolutely and
I would agree with you this stuff has to
come about organically all entertainment
is going to have values in it people
just can't escape this and it's part of
the reason why storytelling has been so
Central to human culture and
civilization because we get our moral
values from the stories that we tell
each other the stories that we're told
as children that we pass on to our
children and so the idea that they're
going to be value neutral is incoherent
it's basically an impossibility point
for the there's no point to a value
neutral storiness how would it exist and
it's exactly it's not even possible the
question is
are these perspectives developing
organically because someone's trying to
tell a story and their worldview is
inevitably going to work itself into it
or is this a piece of propaganda which
exists explicitly to get me to accept
something I might not otherwise accept
that's something interesting too that I
think a lot about
um like Bible stories right so you have
a lot of you know there's been a lot of
critique about the Bible and like from a
liberal world view that this is you know
anti- everybody or whatever but if you
look at the Bible like the stories are
not telling you how things should be
necessarily in the Old Testament yeah
that's interesting they're telling you
how things are right these are our
ancestors expressing their perspective
on life and culture and the world as
they're living in it and they're giving
you that perspective no it's it's an
interesting combination because there
are obviously moments that are
instructive but it's not as if because
something is described in Scripture that
it's being approved exactly and that's
so interesting
um you know and there's well we could go
on for about this for a while but
there's so many interesting stories
where you can see you know the
trajectory of something is not what you
thought like when Joseph gets sold into
slavery in Egypt
um and it turns out that if Joseph
hadn't been sold into slavery in Egypt
all of the Israelites would have starved
to death
yeah so what was the right thing to do I
don't know like that's fast exactly what
I want to mention this I don't take a
more liberal interpretation I I really
do believe in the Bible but at the same
time I find it fascinating that
basically every religious text that I'm
familiar with is narrative in some sense
it's not just a list of things that you
should and shouldn't do there are some
of that right when you look at a
catechism for example that lays out the
rules but it's so clear that humans
understand through story in the
strongest possible way well that's the
group here's everything here's something
interesting the uh old stories I read
this so you guys will have to uh tell me
if it's if it's correct or not but I was
reading this opinion piece about heroes
of the olden days like Hercules and
these these these ancient Heroes who
would challenge the gods fight against
them or the Titans today our heroes are
all a part of the establishment and the
authority Superman and Batman well as
much as they're sometimes at odds like
Batman is a vigilante they still call
upon him and he still upholds the
standard quo Superman does the same
thing I think a lot of comics have done
a great job exploring these ideas in in
real ways that were thought provoking
challenging certain um you know rigid
moral standards we had Captain America
he's basically propaganda in World War
II
then you have this Arc where he he
becomes Nomad he's like I can't stand
for this or you have Civil War where
Captain America is like I will not stand
for the government forcing people to
register you know and and then you have
the industrial as Tony Stark who's like
do what the government wants the
corporation working with government
these ideas were really uh interesting
and it made these comments from one
dimensional to multi-dimensional
challenging our own worldview but in
positive ways now instead of being like
here's an interesting here's an
interesting character Arc Captain
America believes in Freedom the
government wants you to register how
would he handle that now it's just like
you're all racist and you're all bigots
and bigots should be punished and racist
should be excised so the wokeness and
content is just becoming it's reverting
back to the one-dimensional aspect of
old Comics that's just well there was
such an interesting thing that happened
and bizarre when Barack Obama became
president
um and when he was running which is all
of the people who had said up to that
point question authority started saying
trust the government the president is
your friend and it's like it was them
you know people forgot that Barack Obama
was just a politician you know just like
all the other politicians he's very
similar to all of the politicians who
have ruled our country yeah yeah but he
had that painting that said hope yeah
sure right yeah well Shepard Ferry had
the painting he was supposed to end
racism though I feel like that was
supposed to be the deal with Obama but
now the racism
now people say that you know the fact
that we had a black president is doesn't
mean anything at all in terms of the
progress or away from being a racist
country exactly and they'll never say
these kinds of things which I find it
bizarre that's no exactly they'll never
say these kinds of things beforehand
right so when you're supposed to vote
for Obama it's look this is going to be
a giant step towards ending racism of
course they didn't say well look if we
elect Obama that is not at all going to
prove that this is a non-racist country
based on values and not skin colors
Obama wasn't even extremely liberal as I
as I understand I think he was
um against gay marriage when he had
it was a very different time he was
pro-universal Health Care he campaigned
on that in 2007 and eight she also voted
against the born alive act in like 2003
or 2002 as a senator so he was very far
to the left on abortion and not a lot of
economic issues he was as well I think
basically no one in public life was in
favor of gay marriage if they had a
political career at that point yeah
Hillary Clinton I think in 2016 she
wasn't even in favor of gay marriage
like leaked emails came out or something
well let's talk about families though
because we have this this is a story
from the New York Times this is huge
Oklahoma lawmakers approved near total
ban on abortion the measure is part of a
wave of stringent abortion restrictions
enacted by legislators and
republican-led States lawmakers in
Oklahoma on Tuesday approved a near
total ban on abortion making it the
latest republican-led state to forge
ahead with these restrictions the
measure Senate Bill 612 would make
performing an abortion accept to save
the life of a pregnant woman in a
medical emergency a felony punishable by
up to 10 years in prison or a fine of a
hundred thousand dollars now consider
that in an emergency that means the
doctor can be like we've determined that
you know if you keep carrying this baby
within the span of a month or two you
and the baby will die and that's still
not a valid reason to have an abortion
unless I guess you can argue that two
months that time duration that duration
uh is not a contributing factor into
whether it is or isn't an emergency the
felony goes to the doctor not the mother
yeah so yes performing so also when
you're talking about
um these instances of medical necessity
oftentimes what they're referring to is
procedures which are not actually
technically abortions but could result
in the death of the unborn child if they
perform the operation to save the mother
so I'm curious to know which exceptions
are actually being made I think check
this out this is really really
interesting
they say if the passage uh its passage
came after Oklahoma became a major
destination for women from Texas who are
seeking abortions right after that state
enacted a law Banning the procedure
after about six weeks a very early stage
of pregnancy if allowed to take effect
sb612 would be devastating for both
Oklahomans and Texans who continue to
seek care in Oklahoma a coalition of
abortion rights groups including the
ACLU of Oklahoma and Oklahoma call for
Reproductive Justice said in a statement
nearly half of the patients Oklahoma
providers are currently seeing our
medical refugees from Texas now
Oklahomans could face a future where
they would have no place left in their
state to go to seek this basic health
care
I want to point out man
I was I was I asked this question before
I want to avoid making very hard
predictions but
I believe abortion may be a major
Catalyst for this this looming Civil War
or whatever conflict we're in we're at
the point now where it seems things have
calmed down there's a meme where it's
like weird anti-fun BLM go people must
have not been paying their bills and I'm
just like yo it's winter come on come on
yeah they can't be out there now it's
too cool right summer is when things get
crazy and they and they tend to they
only want to fight fascism when the
weather's good it's weird but but also
take a look at what's happening but take
a look at what's happening politically
with like January 6th filing subpoenas
against people they're having to pay
hundreds of thousands of dollars to to
combat these subpoenas they're being
charged with contempt so it's still very
much hot in terms of some kind of
escalating conflict now with Oklahoma
outright being we've got too many
refugees from Texas who want abortion so
we're going to ban it basically outright
this is going to be a major Catalyst
because at the same time this is
happening Colorado does the inverse the
right to abortion in Colorado is now
guaranteed under state law with no
restrictions so my understanding is this
is up to the point of birth is that it
well I read the law and there were no
limits or restrictions so
probably right I mean there wasn't there
were no limitations at all it was a
four-page law
um and yeah it did not it didn't say
that you couldn't have an abortion at
any point blue States there's 15 states
that are similar Colorado wanted
Colorado said that they wanted to be a
sanctuary state for abortion and so did
California and both of those uh
California I know
um was putting money in place in order
to help women who are poor get there so
that they could have their pregnancies
terminated in the state the point is
there's no compromise on this issue at
all anymore there used to be there used
to be compromises Tulsi gabbard saying
safe legal and rare that used to be
Regal I feel like that was even Bill
Clinton that was the that was the old
idea where we are now is Oklahoma says
no Colorado says no problem and there's
like literally no middle ground of like
well maybe there are some conversations
we have about medical issues nope
several years ago a couple years ago
remember it started I think it was Lindy
West started saying shout your abortion
and there was this whole thing about
like be proud of it and I think that
totally backfired you know I personally
have never been in favor of abortion but
I've been like okay safe legal and rare
I guess that makes sense and then as
soon as it started being like
pro-abortion I was like and I'm now
entirely 100 thoroughly I don't think
it's a catalyst for a civil war but I do
think this is a catalyst for a potential
second
um presidential
um term for Joe Biden because I think
this is an issue that so many liberals
and leftists are so passionate about
also I feel like this is an issue that
traditionally right Wingers only played
lip service to I feel like the
Republican party it's made up of three
core groups the neolibs the neocons and
the traditionalists and the only people
who really care about the issue are the
traditionalists also like
Donald Trump only became pro-life when
he was running for president to pay more
lip service to this group another issue
hold on I got to answer at least one of
the points I disagree
um to Democrats this is a virtue signal
but not a strong moral issue Democrats
are not do not Bo so the Democrat view
on abortion is you're flushing away
human waste they consider it no
different than taking a dump in the
toilet they say right so it's just it's
a clump of cells who cares the
conservative position is you murdered a
baby yeah there's a very strong
conservative moral position opposed to
this there is not a very strong moral
position in support of it there's a
virtue signal do you think this is a
number one issue for more Democrats or a
number one issue for more Republicans
it's a good question well I think it's a
number one issue for more Republicans
I'd say Democrats because they Women's
Health means nothing more than abortion
when we talk about women's rights in
this country nowadays we're exclusively
talking about abortions I'll let you get
to your point in a second though no
that's the same thing with this Oklahoma
bill
um where the the same issue that they
faced in Texas was that people people
are just going to different places to
get their abortions and these are really
just affecting poor people differently
but they will just go to other places to
get their abortions you can't take like
Michelle wolf who goes on stage and goes
you get an abortion and you get it
that's disgusting and you can't take
Lena Dunham who says she wished he had
one and compare that in terms of she
wished she had one even though she can't
take that in terms of motivating factor
and compare it to conservatives saying
you are literally murdering babies and
we will stop you it's hard to get in the
middle of this rhetoric but one last
Point that's also going to make this
very difficult to enforce or once it is
illegal or if Roe v Wade was ever
overturned it would go back to the
States but then in the states where it
is illegal the abortion pill and
different Medical Technology exists such
that abortions are extremely easy to
have even without having a doctor so
because during covid we weren't allowed
to meet with doctors that you had to
meet with a doctor to get yourself an
abortion pill prescribed to you but
during covid they lifted that because
they didn't want people meeting with
doctors now since they're changing that
rule they're getting abortion pills
mailed in from different countries and
different continents and there's not a
lot you could do to stop this we're not
going to start making this illegal for
women to get the abortion pill off the
market we're not going to jail them
right that's uh the worst political move
to try to penalize the womb for getting
it I just think it's a losing issue I
want to kind of interject here because
this is I think important issue for me
uh so you mentioned that left Wingers
more or less see this as an arbitrary
medical procedure that people are only
opposing for these archaic religious
reasons on the right people see this as
the termination of a human life earlier
we were talking about the fact that
there used to be middle ground on this
issue I think the fact that there isn't
any more just means that we've all
become more honest with each other and
with ourselves because this isn't an
issue where there can be any Middle
Ground either you're slaughtering a
child or you're not I think with respect
to looking at Alternatives women May
pursue if their state illegalizes
abortion we know that even though people
did flee to other states overall
abortion in Texas went down by about 60
percent so some lives are being saved by
this law again it can be difficult to
quantify but the more States Outlaw
abortion the more more or the fewer
unborn children we will see dying and I
don't think there's any pro-life or
who's going to say that's not a win just
because some people aren't following
that law it's tragic when that law isn't
followed it's tragic whenever an unborn
child is killed but Banning that and
seeing it occur less often is a move in
the right direction Liberals are
motivated by tribal care tribalism care
and fairness they will they will March
if told to March and they typically will
get away with it if that means slamming
banging on the doors of the Supreme
Court you know or Senate building
because Brett Kavanaugh is there and
they scream that he's a violator or
whatever if they're told to do it
they'll do it so you don't need abortion
to motivate the left to go on protest
for something the right is motivated by
very little this is one of the big
issues that has motivated them to
actually get out and protest in fact
there's a progressive pro-lifer right
now she gave a press conference because
apparently she had taken baby parts from
a university that they got access to and
she took them and uh I don't know if I
don't know exactly the full story
apparently she was giving burials to the
babies or something to that effect I'm
not entirely sure
people are trying to claim that she's
like Gosnell too or something like that
but she's actually a progressive
pro-lifer these were given to her like
it was a whistleblower situation oh is
that what it was yeah yeah okay so so
you so when it comes to pro-life
you really just have to look at it like
take a look at how the left describes
the issue of abortion when they're like
what happens if you have a miscarriage
and it's just a clump of cells versus a
baby being killed like people will run
into a burning building to save a baby
they won't run into a burning building
to take a dump yeah there's there's
there's not a mo there's a clear
motivate motivational distinction here
are you guys life at conceptioners yeah
I'm not pro-life but that's a scientific
fact okay uh Libby if you don't mind can
ask that to you too if I think that life
begins at conception yeah yeah I think
it probably does yeah
um I do think though that we are telling
women the wrong story I think we're
telling the wrong narrative about
um what life is about what meaning is
and what being a mother is all about we
tell women that yeah our culture tells
women that
um their lives are limited when they
become mothers that it's going to put a
damper on your ability to do stuff right
and you know to a certain extent yes
there are limitations once you become a
mother you have to prioritize and you
prioritize differently but it's not
going to ruin your life right being a
mother actually makes your life that
much better it's a terrific Bond it's a
very deep bond between mother and child
this is why I'm you know I'm very Pro
motherhood and I think that it's
important to tell women poor women
because you're not you're not seeing the
over-educated
white liberals running around getting
their abortions
antidepressants you are seeing that as
well
um but women are losing their rights in
a lot of other ways this is like the
only right that women are allowed to
fight for they're not allowed to fight
to say that they are women they're not
allowed to fight
or have any of that I want to make I
want to bring it back
your question you asked if life of
conception where were you going with it
I was just going to say um I want to
reject that there isn't a middle ground
on this issue because I do believe I was
looking up the stats to try to find it
specifically but I think most people are
in the country I think it says right now
currently 59 say abortion should be
legal in in all or most cases while 39
say it should be illegal in all or most
cases illegal I couldn't tell what you
said illegal or legal currently 59 say
abortion should be legal in all or most
cases while 39 say it should be illegal
in all or most cases so I think there is
a middle ground in our country I think
people people already generally agree
that less than 20 weeks that's when most
abortions do occur they're cool with
that but late trimester I feel like most
people are on the same page about that
except the people on The Fringe and I
think the the problem with this issue is
that the fringes are the most
um vultures or boisterous uh about this
issue right the extremes are the ones
who care the evangelicals and the
religious people who say it starts at
conception and then you know crazy
abortionists who are who don't care if
it's until the moment of you giving
birth so that's how where the
conversation gets centered around even
though those are the most Fringe cases
and that's the problem why I think some
people don't think there is a middle
ground I think most people in the
country again 59 are cool so I would
agree
because
yeah I think you're I I'll challenge
your stats Gallup has from 2021 48
believe abortion should be legal only
under only certain circumstances
32 say legal under any circumstances and
19 say illegal in all circumstances
which means the majority of Americans
support restriction abortion I'm looking
at Pew public opinion yeah so that shows
and I've also gotten Gallup Gallup says
it's 50 50. and it depends on the
statistics that you're looking at yeah
but I really want to say this so it may
absolutely be the case that there are a
large number of Americans who say that
there's a middle ground here but 95
percent of biologists according to a
five-year study and Survey of biologists
say that life begins at fertilization
regardless of their position on abortion
so the truth is life begins at
fertilization that's what the science
says and I believe that we need to base
our policy around the best information
we have on what human life is and
endowing every living person with said
rights not necessarily what the polls
say might be political absolutely real
quick I do want to point out a large
stats I checked them yup Hugh says
exactly what he says they show I'm
kosher but I will I will I will I will
fake news I will challenge them by
saying when provided with a more nuanced
distinction we we can see from Gallup
three categories as opposed to just two
when you're giving a binary choice on
legal or not some people might be
grudgingly say well I guess then and we
should just have it be legal when given
the option for limited circumstance no
circumstance or any circumstance the
plurality what restrictions in some
capacity as drugs but again more your
poll is common and ubiquitous the
abortion pill is becoming more common
and ubiquitous you will not have to go
to a doctor to receive it in the future
so if women do choose to take the
abortion pill and terminate their
pregnancy what do you think our
government's response should be if there
is no Doctor Who prescribed the pill or
some it's some doctor in India a fake
Doctor Who's just selling pills right so
they acquired the abortion pill and they
chose to terminate their pregnancy how
should we penalize that woman I think
becomes the most politically toxic thing
you could do and that's where it has to
end up we don't want to penalize the
women but I feel like at the end of the
day if they're the one who ends up
making the choice then that's where we
end up that's kind of total [ __ ]
which part so penalizing women wait so
if a woman chooses to take the abort
pill that she got illegally then what
should the if abortion's illegal what
should the penalty you want a jail women
for terminating their I don't want to
make abortion illegal you don't want to
make abortion illegal but if you do if
it is illegal you think that I'm going
down the steps no I'm going down the
only steps that make sense so if we make
a person illegal and somebody chooses to
get an abortion these are just you know
if we make a law should someone be
should someone be you know imprisoned
for attempted suicide
I don't think abortion should be illegal
uh that's not no I don't think my point
is I don't think you should be such a
joke
rationalization which doesn't make any
sense I think you're so I'd like to
respond to this because you're looking
at a very specific circumstances you're
creating a hypothetical scenario where
all abortions are obtained by women
getting these pills I'm talking about
these cases sir so even if that does
become the case there's still going to
be ways to police other forms of
abortion I agree with you that some
things are going to slip through the
cracks that doesn't necessarily mean
you're going to go prosecute women and
it doesn't mean we can't prevent
abortion in other scenarios so how do
you deal with the case so a woman she's
three months pregnant she gets an
abortion pill from India what do you
what are we doing okay first of all
there aren't abortion pills that will
terminate your three-month-old okay so
um like it's the the abortion pills that
exist are pretty early term okay so
let's say very early terms like by the
time you're three months like okay
there's a baby the first trimester 14
weeks so a woman acquires a pill from
India that induces you know an abortion
happened within 14 weeks and it's
illegal in whatever state she does it
too I'm trying to get to the base of it
how do we penalize it there's no doctor
no but I don't think this is getting to
the base but as we're talking about a
restriction that applies to abortions
across the state of Oklahoma at all
points in conception with with a few
potential exceptions do I want to look
into what they're saying with respect to
uh those exceptions you're talking about
a specific scenario of abortion pills
that would be particularly difficult to
prove and prosecution so I think what
needs to happen is you have to ensure
that those pills are not allowed in the
United States of America and anyone who
sells them Insurance
because this would be difficult to
prevent it's not something that we
should attempt to prevent how should we
penalize it okay well yeah
I think Sheamus makes a really good
finish their point before you just start
talking over each other I think Sheamus
makes a really good point which is the
dealer of the abortion pills should be
the one who's child liable good luck
trying to go to India then in those
cases you can't penalize anything that's
true of drugs I think that's the future
of abortion then in our country it's
people illegally acquiring abortion
pills when they can't receive them from
doctors and and I think you can get them
up to 10 weeks I think the future of
abortion pill is going to get it even
further but I think to say that there
are instances that our laws can can
account for is not an argument for why
we shouldn't have these laws in the
first place the the argument is if you
think it should be illegal because it
terminates a human life the issue is
that you can't track early human life so
if you were to view abortion as no
different than a murder the issue is
that someone who is born and has a life
is tracked in some way and when they go
missing the murder typically not always
but will be noticed in some way someone
went missing a woman who gets pregnant
doesn't tell anybody then aborts the
baby there's no evidence of the
existence of the loss of human life if
you were to view it in the exact same
way that it was a murder then the law
should be treating it identically as it
was a murder that is to say it doesn't
matter how the one commit the ACT you
can drive from Illinois to to you know
to Indiana and illegally acquire a gun
and used to commit a murder yeah it's
still illegal so we will penalize the
woman is what I'm trying to get to
because if you think abortion is murder
and then the woman on her own volition
acquires and then boards then she
murdered the child then not necessarily
because intent has a lot to do with this
so if a person doesn't understand what
they're doing they don't recognizing
that they're killing a human person
because no I think there's no point
propaganda women are told that this
isn't murder so I think fighting Wars
for Insanity please no I don't think so
that's that That's the basis of an
insanity plea that you didn't know right
from wrong you can't plead Insanity
because you're literally insane you
plead it you don't know the difference
between right and wrong so if you go to
court and they say you killed this has
happened a woman killed her kids because
she said that once they become 12
original sin will send them to hell
that's insane and then yes yes and so
she bludgeoned her kids to death and
then uh the court said why did you do it
she called the police after she did it
and she was like I need help cleaning
this up my kid I killed them they said
why and she goes to make sure they went
to heaven so she was deemed insane yeah
see that that would be Insanity so the
issue is if you want to penalize
abortion as though it were murder you
would have to treat the woman as a
murderer yes well so basically murder is
handled by the states and I would argue
that as a matter of legislation it makes
sense to be merciful to these women
because oftentimes they literally do not
know what they're doing they're told an
abortion is a procedure just like any
other where they're flushing some cells
out of their body and not a human life I
think so I would absolutely prosecute
the doctors because they know exactly
what they're doing
in any circumstances have no idea I
totally and 100 disagree with you I
think that women women know what
abortion is they know what pregnancy is
and when you're pregnant you can tell
that you're pregnant a lot of things
change about your body very quickly and
you know that you're pregnant you know
that you're carrying a human life it's a
parent
um
uh but you know that you're pregnant you
know what that entails
um no one doesn't know what they're
doing or thinks it really is a clump of
cells except perhaps you know girls
under 16. I do not think that women
should be prosecuted for having
abortions any more than I think people
who are suicidal should be prosecuted
for attempted murder it just doesn't
make any sense
um these things you know these things
are going to happen women have been
aborting their babies since long before
birth control pills or whatever the uh
whatever abortion pills or surgical
procedures or anything like that and
there have certainly been lots of
circumstances in countries in which
women are prosecuted for having
abortions there was um
I was obsessed with Norwegian literature
for a while and there was this book a
growth of the soil I believe was it
growth of the soil Yeah by newtampson
and there was a woman who was prosecuted
for attempted abortion and she ended up
in prison with a whole bunch of other
ladies who had attempted abortions and
they were all there raising their
children in prison and that's the kind
of thing that you would start to look at
you would start to look at imprisoning
children for having been born to mothers
who have a lot of kids and didn't want
anymore as it was in that book was
primarily the situation I think that
what we need to do as a society is have
more respect for parents for parents
choices we have to be supporting
families more and not constantly trying
to you know Force everyone to adhere to
you know the government's dictates for
your lifestyle I think that has a lot to
do with it you know there there is a
chance that the abortion pill doesn't
actually work they say the abortion is
is uh result in abortion one to two
weeks anywhere from fifty four percent
to 92 percent of pregnancies and it also
says if the abortion doesn't take it
could result in birth defects birth if
pregnancy doesn't end so I think I I
would not be surprised if uh they do ban
abortion out right across the board
United States or just in many states
you're going to see people fleeing
States you're going to see people doing
you know backroom abortions or whatever
pills or otherwise but I think what's
more likely to happen first is
um Geographic polarization yeah so like
what we're seeing with women in Texas
fleeing to Oklahoma
if now that Oklahoma bans it you're
going to see people in Texas fleeing to
Colorado yeah and then they're going to
stay in Colorado and then you're going
to see States become hyper polarized by
your it's going to be by geography then
you're going to see a bunch of states
that are pro-abortion with no
restriction and many states that are
anti-abortion with no exceptions or
limited rare exceptions like Health the
mother and then it's going to come down
to the hyperpolarization of this country
control of our institutions and you are
going to have a strong moral issue for
people on the right who are alike you
are literally murdering babies because
we saw it in Virginia
when that woman was her name Tran Nance
what was her name the the that
politician she wanted restrictionless
abortion and she was asked by a judge
would this mean that a woman who is
literally about to give birth she's
dilating you could abort the baby and
she goes there would be no restriction
then you had Northam say well we would
take the baby you would be delivered
it'd be made comfortable and then the
woman would have a conversation with her
doctor about what to do next as if to
imply they would kill the baby after it
was already born there's something he
came out later and he was like I meant
in the case of severe defect I'm like
the baby's alive
well I also so so where does that lead
to if people are going to flee these
states well let me start from here
if Roe v Wade
well it is overturned as many believe it
will especially on the left
many have told me Republicans will not
push for a federal ban abortion because
they think it's a state's rights issue
okay then you get all the blue States
saying no restriction on abortion like
they're doing already 15 states that are
seemingly into that degree and then you
have the red States all saying ban an
abortion with limited or no exceptions
you're going to have hyper polarization
in this country
and that is planting the seeds for
Interstate conflict
we have that in a lot of areas though
also yeah well I find it fascinating I
agree with you and I was just going to
say that that we're going to see
increased polarization just on the basis
of geography left-wing people are going
to leave these red States and then the
blue states are going to become Bluer
the red states are going to become
redder because only people who are
comfortable with those abortion laws
will move there Etc uh you were making a
point earlier just about this being
politically pragmatic and what could
happen is this going to result in Joe
Biden getting a second term I don't
think so but it's also an interesting
question because as we were discussing
earlier
there is a debate here over which side
cares more about this issue we were
pulling up different we were pulling up
different polls that had a bit of nuance
to the the question of abortion asking
do you think it should always be illegal
legal in some circumstances part of the
issue with these is they usually end up
with some kind of framing that could be
considered biased I know that Gallup
poll just straight up asked people do
you identify as pro-life or pro-choice
and it's a pretty pretty neat 50 50
split Across the Nation it's like 49
pro-choice 47 pro-life and then five
percent with no opinion I find it
difficult because too though because in
that framing too I feel like not all
pro-lifers are from conceptioners I
think that's probably true yeah and a
lot like a lot of people consider Plan B
abortions and it gets really and you're
right there's just so many gray zones
there's something to be said about
political principles though and
political strategy because you know I'm
just saying it's a bad strategy that
doesn't mean it's right or wrong
um so I think we have a lot of those
examples in our country who knows this
could be you know although a bad
strategy you're you're being very
principled I think it also kind of
relates to how Trump saying the election
was stolen and pragmatically strategy
wise I don't think it's a great strategy
but he's staying true to his principles
and the people who back him up on those
principles are getting rewarded with his
endorsements so yeah well and I think
part of what sort of adds to to my
position you're here we'll see we'll see
what ends up happening but part of what
I think bolsters my position is the fact
that as Tim said pro-lifer see this as a
child being killed pro-choices just see
this more as in an abstract struggle
between religious Fanatics and the
secularists who want to preserve
people's rights
the question is do you care more about
that kind of abstract battle than you do
the fact that food is more expensive
you're having a harder time feeding your
family gas is as expensive as it's ever
been there's turmoil on the foreign
stage that we probably wouldn't see with
a president who is a little stronger
it's actually a toss-up and you're
probably going to care more about the
things that affect your life in a more
direct sense but if you're going to ask
people to balance those questions
against
another human life they're probably
going to choose to save the person or
believe in Saving the person but in this
instance the pro-lifers don't even have
to make that choice because the people
who they would be voting for not only
want to end abortion but would ideally
be able to to get this country stuff
together and get gas prices down and
return food costs into something more
normal in regard to like the Civil War
stuff though I think it's actually I'm
extremely optimistic because I think
it's a good thing that one of the top
issues that we care about and have to
deal with in our country is abortion
instead of hunger or crazy inflation or
actual I mean I hate using the word
privilege but it's a relatively
privileged position to have this the top
issue you care about and to make a joke
from earlier maybe we might need to not
blame those Russians for the war crimes
in Ukraine because they were
propagandized so heavily well no by the
Russians
so there's an interesting question I'm
rejected I reject the premise so though
obviously but this is the war that the
wars that we're involved in now I know
people who fought in those Wars they
were propagandized as young men to
believe that going to the Middle East
and quote-unquote fighting for our
freedom was the right thing to do they
ended up doing things over there that
they very much regret but I would not
charge them with murder sure I I think
it would you because would you know
because you scoff at this idea that
being propagandized means that you
shouldn't be held accountable there's a
difference between trying to liberate
the Iraqi people and then the war crimes
also committed by certain soldiers on
the ground so if you're on the ground
and massacring people even if you are a
U.S soldier you should be penalized
because that's not what our army teaches
you I would agree and we do by the way
and also the thing is uh but that's the
Iraq War the Iraq War we have the
benefit of it and dealing poorly and
that's why we get to look back at it so
poorly but you know if the if we were
able to set up the problem with Iraq is
that we weren't able to set up a
democracy there after so there's a lot I
didn't ask about work I didn't ask about
things that our nation would consider
war crimes and that our countries I
guess is against in terms of its policy
I'm talking about the United States
being involved in illegitimate Wars
where people died I would say they're
legitimate I wouldn't call them
illegitimate you wouldn't call them
illegitimate even though Congress didn't
declare them well the Congress hasn't
declared a war since World War II am I
calling every war since World War II
illegitimate it no well why not they
didn't go through well process well we
don't do a lot of things by the
Constitution the Congress is the first
thing that's mentioned in our
constitution but you know they barely
have actual power and as much as I'd
like to be a constitutionalist in
practice de facto we have a
commander-in-chief and he's the person
who makes the foreign policy and in our
current world that's the way it needs to
be we can't have our president be
strapped by Congress Congress candidate
then we might not have got involved in
two 20-year long Wars that yeah but the
Senate countless suffering and the
Senate kicks off any kind of the Senate
the senate in Congress is extremely
indecisive and they would get nothing
done we need a leader to be able to act
freely and quickly on the world stage in
my opinion I think also I'm very hawkish
I think most of these wars are Justified
I don't know what to get involved with
Ukraine because I want to be focused on
the Chinese though so that's why I would
justify a lot of these wars not the war
crimes though there is some leniency in
times of war and I understand things get
crazy but as war crimes is a completely
different thing and we do prosecute
Americans who commit Warcraft yeah and I
never said we didn't and I never said
that we shouldn't if someone commits a
war crime they should absolutely be
prosecuted and I think we just plain
don't see eye to eye on the powers of
the presidency the executive branch and
whether we should have been involved in
any of these disasters it feels like
people do Overlook the warcraft because
I was joking originally about the
Russians I do feel like Ukraine's
getting a little bit more extra scrutiny
on their obvious military propaganda
than Russia does we like to talk about
how corrupt Ukraine is which given it is
corrupt but the most corrupt [ __ ] on
planet Earth is actually Russia so do
you know what I'm talking about there
with the given a little bit more slack
to Russia than Ukraine
I'm not as sure on that but I would
agree with you that when you're looking
at that situation I mean I I don't have
a dog in that fight frankly you don't
have butterfly well that's part of why I
don't want to see the United States
government get involved at all even if
there's a country that I would say is
more likely to be in the right I
wouldn't say that the United States
should go defend them or fight for them
oh so you think even if a country is in
the right we shouldn't assist and defend
them it depends on whether it's a
struggle there are certain instances
where it might be necessary for us to be
involved do you think zelenski is heroic
for defending his homeland and
supposedly choosing not to leave and
continuing to fight instead of
surrendering I think yeah yeah I would
think that that's probably a good thing
for a foreign leader to do to stay in
their country and fight if someone's
invading yeah do you think we should be
sending weapons to Ukraine
no I I don't think the United States
government should be involved at all to
be honest okay but then otherwise it
literally just Falls to Russia should we
let should we not let our allies abroad
know that we have their back at any
capacity well Ukraine isn't a part of
NATO and that's part of why they're
having this entire conflict I don't
think it's the United States
responsibility to ensure that NATO or
that uh Ukraine doesn't fall to Russia
sure are you worried that any other
countries will get a hint and a wink and
a nod from the U.S withdrawing from the
global World stage as much are you
scared trigger other conflicts is what
I'm getting well what I think is much
more of a serious risk is the fact that
we have spent the last 20 years involved
in foreign conflicts in the Middle East
and they all ended disastrously in what
we showed other countries is that we're
not serious about fighting the wars that
we do want to fight in the long term
because we don't get involved I think
overall the United States
even if you want to have this more
hawkish approach and say we want to be
more taken more seriously on the foreign
stage we want to show our enemies that
we're not weak
I think a to get the American people on
board with that after you have just
completely failed in your foreign policy
and basically every major respect is
going to be impossible even if you think
that we should or would make us look
good on the foreign stage I mean that
trust has just been completely lost and
that would also say yeah yeah sure I
want to ask you this one last thing this
is what like foreign policy people say
that if we didn't stand at all with
Ukraine that China would get like a wink
and a nod that we're not willing to
defend Taiwan I want to ask you what do
you think about that argument and also
should we defend or Supply Taiwan with
weapons because that's the next step
that's the next Ukraine that's the next
conflict I think that's a really good
question so part of the reason
Ukraine has been such a disaster in my
estimation is that our White House and
Joe Biden our intelligence agencies you
know the
the war machine was basically saying
they believed that that uh Russia was
going to invade and then there were no
precautions taken so I think if we had
established a no-fly zone prior to them
invading that could have deterred them
well I'm not necessarily saying that we
should do that but I am in more position
I don't think so because I think Russia
invades anyway and then if you knocked
out if NATO calls a no-fly zone and then
Russia invades and then they shoot down
a jet that's still World War III and is
my yeah no it absolutely could be uh if
we're talking about Taiwan specifically
though I'd have to look at the situation
I don't I don't have a set position
there I do understand your concerned
that if they get Taiwan that's a big
problem for us um I I looked up the best
date I could possibly find on this issue
abortion doesn't weigh particularly
heavily for either party but there's a
plus five Republican
um percentage so when it comes to the
issue of abortion Republicans at 28 view
it as a top issue Democrats at 23 and
Independence at 25. so Republicans do
have the plus five that is to say when
all of these changes are happening with
abortion it doesn't seem like it will be
the biggest motivating factor but it
will it will be more likely to motivate
Republicans than it would Democrats it's
interesting that climate change is up
top there yeah did you see the
Republicans
but it's interesting because
um did you see there was some data that
came out from OkCupid and Tinder that if
you don't care about climate change it's
a deal breaker the ladies are not going
to go out with you as a matter of fact
they came up with this term Petro
masculinity to describe the combination
of um of the man who is uh you know of
course racist but uh is anti-climate is
racist is Nationalist and is misogynist
so if you don't think that climate
change is a super big issue then you're
apparently petro-masculine and this is a
problem I care about climate change as
much as Barack Obama does I'm gonna buy
my beachfront property and I'm gonna
relax yeah I liked it because the other
thing too is the the data didn't say
that the person that you're interested
in had to
um be interested in taking any action on
climate change or doing anything it was
just if you care about it like if you
really feel deeply about it and make
sure you bring your recycled bag to the
market when you buy your foie gras or
whatever does it say which direction you
have to care deeply in because what if I
care about causing more climate change I
like this my favorite part too is that
nobody ever remembers that fossil fuel
actually resulted in the greatest
decrease in global poverty the world has
ever seen
and free trade shout out to that but yes
um love that one last thing because I
just had it on my mind for sure I don't
think it's enough to just be
anti-communist domestically and and I
islamist uh domestically I do think that
if we believe in these values then we
should try to export them and make sure
that people aren't attacking those
values worldwide and that's why I stand
so strongly with Taiwan it's not enough
to be anti-communist back home you need
to be anti-communist internationally
that's why I stand with South Korea
Japan that's why we need to work closer
with Australia and India we really need
to box the Chinese and they are the you
the next geopolitical threat we do not
want to live in a multi-polar world
we're trying to get to call shots on
even playing field as us they view every
part of our system as negative and bad
we'd want less of that Chinese Communist
influence here see I wish people would
be honest about that because uh uh I
often tell people if you like the way I
I said this about Hillary Clinton I'm
like if you like the status quo you know
if if you like that we get our shirts
made in Indonesia if you like that it's
a nickel an hour to make your shoes you
got to vote for Hillary Clinton if you
have a problem with that and War and the
international policies that exploit
foreign countries you'll want a Donald
Trump because he's all about America
First and what's manufacturing here
which will make things cost more money
in the long run but typically everyone
everyone's standard of living will go up
quite a bit I think I don't think it's
exploiting I think it's helping these
other countries and it's so interesting
when we talk about these prices going up
and how much people care it's because
like oh I mean hey we'll make it
domestically and then shirts will be a
little bit more expensive the Americans
won't care this is coming from the same
people who constantly say oh gas is up
two more dollars Joe Budden is
definitely gonna lose the election
because of this so I feel like some
people are having it both ways when
they're talking about that though but do
we care about higher prices
you're making a mistake Donald Trump was
in favor of energy Independence in the
United States which was lowering gas
prices sure so you can complain about
Joe Biden's failed policy energy
policies the United States the reason
you know you know why we give 12 million
dollars to Pakistani gender studies to
maintain the strength of the Petro
dollar we want to give people money and
say use it use it it's valuable that way
they say okay I'll get something for
this Donald Trump was like secure our
borders better trade deals manufacturing
back home that would have made many
things cheaper would have made some
things more expensive all in all the
quality of life for everybody was going
up we were seeing businesses enacting
32-hour work weeks we were seeing paid
parental leave these things were
happening organically because the
economy was booming as Jim Cramer had
the best number of our lives but numbers
of our lives but some people they like
the idea of for whatever reason actually
I'll put it this way I think if you
actually know what the Democrats have
been doing for 30 years along with the
neocons don't get me wrong things have
changed in the past five years with
Republicans not too much but a little
bit they were exporting American Wealth
they were extracting from the system as
a Dylan Radigan called it if he was
referring to the same thing and it was
resulting in American lives being worse
off for people getting angry and there
was a backlash so if you want to export
American neoliberalism and
neo-conservative values then you want to
do everything you're saying I suppose if
if neoliberal is free trade and neocon
is you know established our values are
worldwide and not let our allies get
stumped then yeah kind of down with it
yeah
we change other countries political
structure based on what we in the United
States have determined would be
advantageous to us so when we go to the
Middle East and say you know what let's
turn Afghanistan into a democracy even
though it's a completely unpragmatic
goal that we could never achieve and
then we waste 20 years over there uh
trillions of dollars thousands of human
lives that's what neoconservatism is
that's what its record has been so you
can talk about defending our allies but
all we have done is gotten people killed
and made the situation worse over there
then
this is a really good point though time
people don't want to live in a
multi-polar world where China is calling
the shots or at least putting an equal
says and yeah and and people don't want
that but the challenge I suppose is many
people don't want to see Americans being
shipped off to foreign countries in what
is what is typically viewed as Conquest
invading Iraq and Afghanistan for vague
or incorrect reasons for the sake of
expanding our power in these regions I
think we need to continue to support our
allies both uh militarily and
economically because in the zero-sum
game of foreign policy if it isn't us
helping out our allies it's them going
to our enemies what does that mean what
does that mean it means that hey if we
choose not to um be friendly to the
Philippines and when China you know acts
aggressively in the South China Sea and
um navigate through their Waters with
impunity that we need to defend the
Philippines and let them know that we
have their back okay we get that I'm
talking about like you know invading
Iraq and Afghanistan and firing missiles
into Syria so I I mean hey if right now
let's do it into a modern day issue
right now if Iran is acquiring nuclear
weapons are we going to do anything
about it why if they do should we do
anything about it why why should we do
something about it yeah why should we
because I don't think I ran an
autocratic islamist regime who's
threatened to wipe multiple of our
allies off the map should have nuclear
weapons what do we do about it
um well so far it's been the jco jcpoa
the Iran deal that we've been like one
foot in and one foot out of and then
it's also through our proxy actually it
was stuxnet yeah and now we have their
their centrifuges and now we have our
proxy allies too like Israel who are
constantly you know harming Iran one way
or another development to keep it to the
modern issues
would you you're you're I suppose you're
arguing in support of the the corruption
in Ukraine and the missile strikes on
Syria so it's not I I hate that I think
the Russian I think Russia is the most
country on planet Earth moreover you
know Vladimir Putin is a former KGB
actual Soviet communist so we shouldn't
have a lot of faith in this guy and
obviously zelinski isn't a perfect
figure but I'll tell you who's a lot
further from perfect it's Vladimir Putin
who actually poisons his political
opposition and has committed war crimes
in the past and now what it looks like
is continue to do so in Ukraine so uh
like Syria right the U.S we kind of
pulled out of there and unfortunately
we're back you know thank you Joe Biden
as I understand like Russia rules the
airspace and that's part of the reason
why Israel hasn't come as
um hard out against uh Russia as they
could have but I mean why how did these
jihadis and these Rebels end up with
um nato-backed weapons in Afghanistan in
Syria and Syria
some of the Rebel groups originally and
the West wanted Isis to destabilize
Syria because we wanted to build a gas
pipeline we wanted to get rid of Bashar
al-assad because we wanted to build a
gas pipeline there are a few reasons we
wanted to get rid of well the main
reason is that in 2009 the CIA wanted to
invade because we were trying to build a
pipeline from Qatar through Syria and
turkey into Europe to offset the gas
Prime Gas Monopoly which goes through
Ukraine yeah Ukraine subsequently now
we're involved in a conflict in that
country because well surprise surprise
Joe Biden once he gets put in charge his
son happens to get a job uh become a
director for a gas company in Ukraine I
think we want regime change all of this
is tied together we wanted to change
regime change in Syria because they were
a Russian Ally and everything else comes
after that
but do you know why we wanted regime
change because they're Russian allies we
want us because when we said we want to
build a gas pipeline to offset the
Russian gas Monopoly with gas prom
Bashar al-assad told the United States
allowing you to do that would upset our
Ally Russia this was reported in the
guardian back in like 2012 the U.S
wanted to invade instead a civil war
breaks out the rebels are given
nato-backed weapons and a truck from
Detroit with some guy's phone number on
it which created a huge crisis for this
guy's poor company and it was
destabilizing the entire region was the
West basically being like Europe
deserves cheap gas now if you like the
idea of Europe having cheaper gas
because Russia is gripping them by the
balls then just be honest about it that
the U.S is willing to destroy entire
regions and create chaos in Ukraine and
Syria for the sake of their allies if
you like your wealth just admit it I
think it's much bigger than just gas
going through Syria I think Syria has
been uh become a proxy essentially for
Iran and that's why we're fighting their
multiple countries are fighting on
multiple sizes one of the most
complicated conflicts in the Middle East
but their Iranian proxies and we don't
want Iranian proxies to win out in Syria
next to our other allies and we don't
want Iran to continue to spread their
influence same things going on in Yemen
with the houthi rebels attacking our
other allies through the Saudis the
Saudis are backing and and us having a
blockade up that starved 84 000 children
to death sure again the we haven't acted
properly in all these cases and there
have been consequences to our actions
but I feel like if we're overlooking
constantly the misdeeds of our enemies
who are much greater and larger than
ours then we're really missing the point
have they starved 85 000 children to
death who has are our enemies so no
don't get me wrong the Hootie Rebels are
terrible our enemies have done worse
yeah and the houthis they're all they're
yeah
so then we should get involved and have
the United States backed blockade that
has literally starved tens of thousands
of children to death stand even after
Joe Biden says we're not going to be
involved in this conflict anymore
because some people in that region also
did bad things it's a zero-sum game it
either comes down to do we want them to
be in our sphere of influence or the
Iranian and Syria Iranian and Russian
and if they if Iranians and Russians and
Chinese continue to exert their
influence and expand this is just going
to come to bite us back in the ass
further down the line yeah I mean this
is the unit this all has to do with the
unipolar world order that the United
States currently has and and I think
that's what conservatives probably
should conserve and we need to do that
by continuing to assist and support our
allies in the zero-sum game of
geopolitics if they're not with us
they're going to our enemies well I
don't believe in child sacrifice he's
been in the name of supporting our
allies well this is not sacrifice come
on
thousands of children and dying starving
the words happening regardless and we're
supporting one side the conflict is
happening right now if we didn't support
Ukraine the conflict would still be
happening and the Russians are still
going to be massacring people so I'll
tell you the Russians have killed kids
United States is funding and backing the
blockade that is starving the children
that's my point if we weren't doing that
those children would not be sorry I
don't want to go in circles because
we've said that several times my
question is uh you said the conflict
would still be happening in Ukraine how
come there was no conflict in Ukraine
when Trump was president
oh I mean because Putin was scared of
trump in my opinion
yeah yeah I think he like leaders did
not were not able to predict what Trump
would do I think on the world stage
people do not respect Trump and I mean
do not respect Biden at all as I
understand Joe Biden just had his phone
called ignored by Muhammad bin Salman
the current leader of Saudi Arabia Trump
would not have allowed that to happen
Trump the first place that Trump visited
was Saudi Arabia if they did anything
like that you know Trump is freaking out
on Twitter or something yeah or anything
and he's holding them to account Saudi
money is the most influential money in
DC Trump would not let that stuff slide
if Trump was in office right now I think
we'd have more of our allies on a
Stranglehold but I'm also conflicted
because the Saudis have now become
political the Saudis chose not to pump
oil I don't want to jump around too much
think about that under Donald Trump
we didn't have the conflict in Ukraine
Putin was scared of him I agree with
that I also think Donald Trump was
actually CR he was crushing Isis he
didn't care about Syria he was like get
rid of Isis whatever but but you know
the the Democratic establishment the
neocons and the neolibs were like let
Isis destabilize Assad's regime and then
you know we can come and pick up the
pieces or leave him in rubble as we
build under trump our border was more
secure our economy was way better and
there was less war would you consider
Trump a neocon no it's interesting
because he his chief of staff I forgot
exactly who it was but he's been called
the neocon yeah
well he wasn't surrounded by he
appointed yes yes yes absolutely and
then he also was a big proponent of NATO
again he sounded anti-natal but what he
was really saying was everybody should
increase their budget to like the
percent of GDP that they should be
paying the United States he was a close
supporter of Japan
um for the purposes of Taiwan stood very
strong with Israel so again this could
be
not that's all it's it's it's America
First populism and and he's ending with
NATO Israel and Japan is America First
populism under Trump just we wouldn't
expect someone who's in America First
populist to walk in and be like as of
today there's no NATO anymore he went to
them and said why are we paying your
bills all these people want to come out
and brag about their oh Europe's got all
this health care and it's like how much
do do we cover their the like how many
trips do we have in Germany thirty
thousand some ridiculous is it 30. I
think it's more some ridiculous number
we're footing the bills for that Trump
comes and says you got to pay us if you
want this service because he was focused
on America first I think that might be
the cost of the unipolar world though
and if that's the cost to pay the cost
of uh being a universe the world that's
why we have eight aircraft carriers
he got Europeans to pay yeah he got them
to pay there
yeah yeah and I'd argue that he was a
neocon because of things like that
increasing military funding he was also
sending more support he was anti-war
he's anti-war through strength and
that's what I consider he has people to
pay their their bills he increased
military funding and he also supported
our allies militarily more and I'd
consider that and the neocons and the
neolibs wanted to invade in the Middle
East they liked Isis destabilizing the
region instead Trump had no new Wars he
under his administration got the Abraham
Accords unprecedented peace in the
Middle East there was no conflict with
Ukraine the region was starting to
stabilize the economy United States was
substantially better than it had ever
been but the dude just couldn't shut up
to save his own president his own his
own you know second term he couldn't
save those two Congress those two Senate
seats in Georgia either and had to give
back the Senate to Joe Biden which I
feel like is an overlooked sin that
Donald Trump committed again this was at
the time with of a lot of the election
fraud stuff was just bubbling yeah he
convinced people not to vote it was it
was just I can't believe how remarkably
stupid that was yeah and that was
campaigning right now around the country
to continue supporting candidates who
will only say that the election was
stolen and if you back up back off that
a little bit like Mo Brooks did he'll
withdraw will send the endorsement too
so well the conservatives shouldn't
shouldn't keep focusing on Trump as the
main guy I think it's this you know I
think DeSantis is great I would totally
throw support behind to Santa's I think
he's been doing great things in Florida
and I think that
um you know his leadership for the rest
of the country would be incredibly
effective parents all across the State
of Florida support him his his uh
anti-grooming bill you know as his press
secretary coined it is wildly popular
across the country with parents as well
it is but it's not even an anti-grooming
bill it's just like a minor restriction
on yeah I mean what it says is that
teachers in grades K-12 cannot Broach
topics yeah okay through three exactly
cannot Broach uh topics of sex sexual
classrooms orientation on gender
identity and orientation it says that
they can't bring it up it says they
can't have classroom instruction not
that they can't bring it up they're
allowed they're allowed to bring it up
they're allowed to discuss it teachers
are allowed to go to Children uh in
certain circumstances that are four four
or five years old and talk to them all
about orientation and identity they
can't the bill specifically says
classroom instruction
which is a very specific way of talking
about how you go about the class like
how you go about teaching because they
could say I'm not instructing the kids
on anything I simply told about what me
and my boyfriend do and that's allowed
and if a child goes to a teacher and
says I have questions about something
the teacher is still allowed to talk to
him about it
so the bill is for many conservatives a
half measure but the left has framed it
so dramatically as don't say gay that
many conservatives are treating it like
it actually does something that they
would like when in reality it's like oh
yeah some grades won't have curriculum
but the teachers can still talk about it
well anyway
across the country and I think that
they're keeping secrets
um and it does say that if children ask
about things that they should tell their
parents I uh well it doesn't it doesn't
say that it says they can't tell the
students not the teachers can't tell
students to withhold information but
they don't need to tell the kids to talk
to their parents no but it says that
they will talk it says that the teachers
are supposed to tell the parents about
mental physical uh uh mental medical or
physical issues right but if a child
goes to the teacher and says what's
trans mean the teacher can say whatever
they want and tell no one so it's it's
not this bill that it's not an
anti-grooming bill
as I understand critical race Theory a
core tenet of critical race theory is
talking about like lived experiences and
although that my evidence might show
otherwise that your lived experiences
are more valuable than anything else and
what I was trying to get at here is that
I had a gay teacher once um it was in
fifth grade as I remember he was a nice
teacher he used to give out candy and
everything
um Ten Years Later it came out and it
was like found that he was actually a
sexual predator and touching kids and um
that's my whole story critical race
Theory lived experiences that's that's
the only thing I have to contribute to
the anti-grooming bill let's go to super
Chats on that note yes if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends smash that like button at uh
we're gonna have a real really fun
members only segment coming up around 11
or so p.m tonight so become a member at
timcast.com if you want to watch and we
will read your super chats and uh what
did I say smash the like button all
right let's see what we got here we got
a whole bunch of Super Chips everybody's
arguing we're arguing
cygnus says thanks for keeping honest
journalism alive Tim been a follower
since 2019. you seem to be the most
reliable source of mainstream political
global news today well I try my best I
really do appreciate it I get things
wrong because I can only know what
people are reporting and what we can
fact check and often can I just say it
says School District a school district
may not encourage classroom discussion
about sexual orientation or gender
identity in primary grade levels is that
the actual Bill yes the actual bill says
uh classroom instruction a school
district may not encourage classroom
discussion about sexual orientation or
gender identity in primary grade levels
or in a matter that is not
age-appropriate or developmentally
appropriate for students where are you
reading that from I'm reading that from
page three of the parental rights and
education Bill and so that's talking
about school districts providing
encouragement not what teachers can or
can't do individually
um it doesn't say that but it also says
that parents can bring action against
right a school district but it can it
can't I mean can it say teachers can and
cannot say x I think it I don't know
that that's it literally says classroom
instructions that's what I just said but
you're reading a different passage from
it may not encourage classroom
discussion right that your school
districts may not that means like a
superintendent putting out a message on
a curriculum that's not talking about a
teacher literally walking up to a group
a group of girls at recess and saying do
you guys don't know what trans is
because it doesn't prohibit that it
that's still allowed they can't what it
does stop them from doing is saying
don't tell your parents they can't do
that yeah they're not allowed to keep
any secrets which is different they are
allowed to keep secrets they just can't
tell the kids to keep secrets so if a
kid asks the teacher what does it mean
to be gay the teacher can tell them the
word teacher does not appear in the bill
right because it's it says School
Employees in the classroom or whatever
right
so it specifically says classroom
instruction for kindergarten to third
grade it doesn't say school it doesn't
employee isn't in the bill either what
are you talking about I don't know if
you're reading the right Bill I'm
reading the Florida parental rights and
education final the final one the
Florida Senate SB 1834 I don't know I
I'm pretty sure you're reading something
wrong really yeah uh control F for
classroom instruction and read the
passage
because this uh initially earlier
versions of the bill says said Pre-K and
they actually changed it to kindergarten
but I'll keep reading while you search
okay all right Chris Larson says hey Tim
been a daily listener since hearing you
on Joe Rogan and love the work you do
what do you think uh what do you think
about this uh if DeSantis wins the
primary so Trump runs independent thus
splitting the Republican votes I don't
think they would do that I think it's
possible that Trump runs with DeSantis
gets one more term and the DeSantis runs
as his VP as being the VP he then runs
for president gets two terms but it's
possible I honestly don't know for sure
Trump will have to allow DeSantis or
he'll have to wait his turn like if
Trump runs I think the Santa's political
calculations has to be don't
all right what do we got here
Tim Chrysler says you should check out
the the S2 underground YouTube channel
titled fifth generation fifth generation
Warfare might connect some dots for you
and your crew we actually get accused of
talking about fourth and fifth
generation of warfare too much
but uh definitely interested in checking
that out
all right Hefty jungle says Hey shimcast
and crew it's my birthday gonna get a
shout out fellas have a nice night from
the shimcast crew here over at shimcast
Central we want to wish you a happy
happy birthday and another wonderful
year of Life hopefully many more than
that
samikin says why do people buy 19.99
super chats and not 20. is there an
unspoken rule that you shouldn't buy a
20 super chat if you buy a Super Chat
and it has a cent instead of a full
dollar amount you are using an iPhone
this in my opinion is likely done by
Google to differentiate who is using
Android and who is using iPhone because
the Android app does fall dollar
increments and iPhone iPhone drops it by
one penny although I find that strange
because with the insane amounts of
people who use iPhone they're seriously
losing a lot of money because pennies
add up and if there's a million iPhone
users who send one Super Chat you're
talking about thousands what is it a
million divided by a hundred so you're
looking at 10 grand
but uh that's that seems to be why they
do it I don't know exactly why they do
it but that seems to be the
differentiating factor if you're on a
computer or Android phone then it is a
full dollar increments
Hunter Biden's crack pipe says those
aren't stink bugs they're NSA spying
drones right uh little did we know my
friends there's an app called Akinator
Aki m-a-t-o-r yeah and what you do is it
says think of a character real or fake
and I'll guess who it is by asking
questions it's fun and so you'll think
of somebody like we did Sheamus and it
was like is your person a YouTuber and
we're like yes it's like is he animated
and we're like no he's not animated and
then it's like no he said he was we said
he was animated right no no we're
talking about you personally to see if
you would come up but ultimately it said
after 30 questions it was like you're
thinking of Freedom Tunes we're like wow
but it it doesn't ask anything overtly
specific and and so then I ended up
doing Hunter Biden the last question
this is hilarious is like does he scam
people and I put yes and then it's like
you're thinking of Hunter Biden and it
shows a picture of him in bed with a
crack pipe in his mouth and I'm just
like wow that's the photo they're using
all right then
I think I think beneath the censorship
surface people really don't like the
establishment dude I just about died
because we yeah we were doing that at
breakfast they're just trying to like
figure out who it would guess and people
we know and it was very very interesting
to see who was in that system I would I
would recommend y'all
play with it it's a lot of fun miss
Norma's first name Dixie says Tim and
crew please keep the town of Pembroke GA
in your prayers this evening a bad
tornado tore through this afternoon
leaving many injured thank you well sad
to hear it man
sad to hear it
all right Mike S says what Millennial
kid did not want to be one of the Ninja
Turtles I was legit Michelangelo for
several several Halloweens I am glad my
parents didn't actually surgically
turned me into a turtle I didn't want to
be a ninja turtle I wanted to be an
X-Man I was like yeah and I was like you
know Cyclops could shoot laser beams out
of his eyes Wolverine he was like super
cool because he could you know hit Claws
and
sh I would I want it to be jam gem from
Gem and the Holograms oh wow yeah gem I
wanted to be able to go Super Saiyan I
didn't want to be one of the characters
I just wanted to be able to go super
have the abilities yeah yeah I've tried
to what I what I liked about Dragon Ball
Z is that they at least entertained the
possibility of humans being able to be
super powerful and I like characters who
can earn their abilities not just have
them so that's why I like Batman that's
why I like Dragon Ball Z because like
Krillin the strongest human being on the
planet and then he's like I'll chill
about it but he's just ridiculously
powerful and he could fly well Tim I saw
a tweet that said Batman superpower is
White Privilege so get wrecked that
that's that's actually true it's
actually true oh whoa wouldn't it have
been the money yo that's a really good
idea that he had the money that's
actually a good idea for a bit or a
comic it's a guy who uses White
Privilege as a superpower oh my gosh but
he does well that's how they see
themselves they say I'm using my white
privilege to help marginalize people
maybe you should make a comment a
cartoon about it
all right Ryan grisaff says check the
dates Elon pushed for the Buy on March
14th that's more than a week before he
pulled people he definitely has some
ideas and plans coming I'd love to see
it you know the fact that he called The
Babylon B guys was uh was indicative of
something
muad says last time Libby was here she
said her by her standards she didn't
think we've ever had a good president
does she still feel that way
a good president
not even Woodrow Wilson
I think uh I've been reading a little
about about LBJ lately I think he's sort
of interesting
um but I gotta say I liked uh you know I
liked Trump
I don't you know Kevin Reed says me me
and my wife watch her so show every
night she would love if you shared to
the chat Isaiah chapter 24 verse 1
through 23 keep up the good work do you
know what that is wait can you repeat
that Isaiah chapter 24 verse 1 through
23 no but I can Google it Google it
we'll see what that's all about Isaiah
wait Isaiah I have to I could pull it up
right here on my phone well you guys are
pulling it up let's read more
let's see so this is the tweet I
mentioned earlier this is tus nalorem
it's not a platform because liberals
have platforms far from it those
platforms were all conservative ones the
left wormed into and called theirs
commies don't have ideas don't create
they take they conquer things that work
to call them their own retroactively
well when
um when Reddit was first started one of
the default subreddits was atheism so
yeah it wasn't overtly conservative but
it was very civil libertarian at the
very least so very meritocratic I just I
think jailbait was also uh subreddit so
definitely libertarian leaning that
wasn't a default though it wasn't a
default yeah atheism so when you would
go to Reddit it would show you as like
one of their main forms atheism and
people were like why hmm you know like
people genuinely were just like
it would be it'll be the same as if they
had a Christianity subreddit as a
default it's like a religious like let
people have their Community for sure but
the default should be like picks videos
news it didn't even have news there was
no news default that was the weirdest
thing
I don't think they have defaults now
they just have like all or something
also when people say it was conservative
I think it's just because the definition
of conservative has changed so rapidly
over there okay did you see that super
chat about my pencil which one they say
all right it says Lobby which my Jack
how much autocorrect does that too Lobby
is holding my favorite pencil Blackwing
602. that's correct I love this pencil
who's who's this sexist saying
Enterprise is better than Voyager who
said that word half the pressure twice
the speed
I man um should we say their name say
his name oh um scrotz magout says
Enterprise
see my problem with voyager is that
that's just not even who was it I didn't
realize who wasn't appointed this out
Voyager is the first female Captain
first female captain and it's a show
about her getting lost the whole series
as they get lost like and they're trying
to get back home for all seven seasons
also they had they had such a
antagonistic characters I much prefer
the characters you know that work
together and they face conflict together
instead of constantly being at each
other's throats yeah Voyager is all
right though Enterprise just just it's
yeah it's not bad it's just prequels man
that's boring you know what the thing is
it has like you know what its future is
you know where it's going so who cares
like it's the yeah and it was It was
kind of the first time that Star Trek
decided it was going to try to be
something other than Star Trek they were
they were trying to like update it and
bring it into the 2000s wait wait hold
on ghost Crusader says hey Tim did you
see the teaser trailer for Picard season
three yes they released the season three
season three teaser a year before they
release season three well season two
isn't over yet
I stopped watching season two anyway I
yeah I don't watch it I was like doing a
whole Arc a whole season based on one
cue plot yeah I'm just like also Q
doesn't really yeah because they made
him they made him look cute yeah they
made him kind of not nobody's having any
fun on that show that's a problem Star
Trek has a lot of fun they hate fun
remember
the lefties hate but I can't write
anything right Q gets his power is taken
away from him and then he's like I don't
want to live anymore and then he ends up
redeeming himself so they give him his
powers back and and he teleports to the
Enterprise uh Bridge with a sombrero and
maracas with a mariachi band playing
great and the new and now what they're
doing is he's like it's time for Penance
pick hard and I'm like what is this and
then he sends them to a universe where
humans are all racist and I'm just like
come on like can we just be done with
this let's let's have something fun
hopeful energetic interesting about the
future of humanity that doesn't suck but
it's like we can only Envision ourselves
as a massive suck Fest you know we hate
life we hate Humanity
we should make a show called we hate
ourselves
and it'll be about the galactic Republic
you know what if it's like the galactic
monarchy they have space travel they
just revert back to monarchy and
everyone decides that that's going to be
the thing in the year 20 in the 2300s
everyone realizes monarchy is the
perfect form of government it's funny
because these shows are like very
hegalli and the idea is they've they've
finally achieved the perfect political
system and ended history but it's just
you have one world government I think
would be interesting if you had a Sci-Fi
series where the world was extremely
technologically developed but like
people had their own ideas and not
everyone was on the exact same page
ideologically that'd be interesting yeah
but instead it's like no we're all on
the same team and we believe this and
it's it's just all right Malcolm Flex
says band for the third time on Twitter
only gained 3K in my ALT profiles from
this stint gonna have to ask Elon to
unban all three of my accounts good luck
yeah wait do you see the one about how
there should be Indie artists that daily
wire should bring up India Santa says
daily wire should bring in Independent
Artists like Tom McDonald Adam chellen
snow and actors that's been blacklisted
by Hollywood they are yeah I can't say
too much we're going to be in Nashville
next week hanging out at the daily wire
headquarters it's going to be a whole
lot of fun but we've been talking to
them about quite a bit because obviously
we're doing cultural stuff too a lot of
our stuff is you know similar but
different they're doing traditional
Hollywood approach I think they're now
trying to do a social media thing we've
been way more social media I announced
earlier that we're going to be doing a
100 000 ad buy for chicken City no
that's awesome and it was funny because
people got mad at me for it a lot of
people laughed and I was like if you
don't understand why we would do
something like that then uh then you
don't understand culture chicken City
obviously chicken culture
chicken city is our second highest
grossing show because we launched
chicken party I got to see the chicken
party today when whenever there's a
hundred thousand super chats it triggers
a chicken party with lights and dance
music now I'm gonna break it down for
people don't understand why we would
spend so much money promoting chicken
party and I'm just gonna come out and
say it
promoting buying a commercial that is
completely insane and putting it on TV
is marketing for the entire company
because people will say what did I just
watch it's like Quiznos that's what I
said when I saw chicken party exactly
Quiznos did a commercial with these
weird things singing you know remember
that weird commercial yeah
oh yeah and they teach that in marketing
classes at colleges they were like this
was one of the most successful campaigns
because it was so insane they used to do
ads where there was like a picture of a
woman on a swing with three legs
they would do things to try and make you
go what and you you your brain would be
shocked by it you'd remember it we are
not just willy-nilly doing things the
point of chicken city is to make
commercials that actually promote the
entirety of the company and the weird
cultural stuff we're doing while trying
to be just silly fun and just not boring
stodgy garbage plus I gotta bounce with
you guys chicken city is wildly
successful it's really cool like several
hundred dollars per day generated from
people just wanting to see the chicken
party so it's working really several
hundred dollars a day from people who
just want to see chicken yeah I think we
did 300 bucks the other day I should
tune in more some more chicken parties
we're still refining the system that's
the way it works right now is more than
animation makes on YouTube bro whenever
whenever a hundred dollars there's a
meter and whenever a hundred dollars
reaches the meter resets and that
triggers a um uh in the code it's uh it
basically I'll give you the very
simplified version there is every five
minutes the the uh the computer checks
does x equal you know does X increment
plus one
if the answer is yes chicken party plays
but only on the fives so 0 5 10 15 20
25. so if the problem we're facing is
that people will uh people will pay 100
bucks at like you know 901 am and it's
got to wait four minutes until the check
runs so we don't have a system that can
so what we're going to do is we're gonna
we're gonna put chicken party activated
like a timer showing you on the fives
that you can party we'll play but um
people are people someone give us 75
bucks today because they were like let's
see the chicken party and they paid it
people love seeing the chickens and the
lights and that's because it's cool and
they love supporting Tim cast well
ultimately the reason we do stuff like
chicken chicken City we're gonna buy
Billboards we remember we talked about
doing our pillow you guys remember that
we are going to be creating culture and
the point is
I think about Elon Musk buying Twitter
and I've always asked this I tweeted
Elon Musk a while ago why didn't you
build an Iron Man suit yet and he's he
tweeted at me building Starship and I
was like that that is acceptable that's
at least a good reason why aren't more
people with access and privilege doing
anything interesting and so my my issue
is like I want to make this company
something that is like a roguish company
that is screwing with the system that is
culture jamming that is just shaken
things up a little bit and inspiring
people to be active and to make things
more fun thing that I really like is
that you're not doing this with an
ideological brand there's no political
you know I mean Freedom Theory because
freedom is not political freedom is like
you know a human right and natural right
um but I like that it's really about the
Aesthetics it's about fun it's about you
know enjoying
um the content enjoying the imaginative
creative curious process that goes into
developing developing that kind of stuff
I think that that's what we need more of
I think we need so much more of that and
we used to have more of that and it got
completely co-opted by ideologues it's
time to just break out of that it
doesn't matter what your political
perspective is have fun create stuff
build things I like what the daily wire
is doing for sure the Jeremy's razors
commercial but let's read more we got
Captain apathy says Tim the left is
countering the groomer narrative with
talking about the very strange HB 233 in
Tennessee the home state of the daily
wire I don't know what that is do you
guys want to uh sure Victor Rodriguez
says Mr Freeze's quote at the end I
failed you I wish there were another way
for me to say it I cannot I can only beg
your forgiveness and pray you hear me
somehow someplace someplace where a warm
hand waits for mine dude that I I feel
like they could redo it again so I I the
episode is still a little campy for what
it is but it was like one of the first
times they're like hey let's give a a
Villain Like a tragic backstory and not
make him just this like you know like
Joker's crazy he's cool but the Joker
movie was incredible because they made
him this like in the movie Joker you
kind of understood why he was pissed off
that you guys have seen Joker right the
last joke when he's sitting on stage
with uh Robert De Niro you get what you
effing deserve I was just like oh man
like that movie was amazing I love them
Tim I wanted to ask you I know I didn't
send a super chat but on this idea of
building culture because I know you guys
focus on it a lot you guys say that at
the same time as you say like leave the
cities and I'm a brooklynite right now
every inch of Brooklyn in Manhattan is
Iconic do you guys feel like you might
be missing out on helping build or
develop Culture by not being in the city
or different cities like New York City
that's you know fashion capital of the
world Broadway everything that's 20
years ago you don't think still every
inch of Manhattan's iconic you don't
think you could have more cultural
impact there no that's too that you're
too restricted you can't be loud it's
like you know Casey and I said that a
lot with New York and he broke the law a
lot yeah he was flying drones around
then like getting in trouble he was like
driving in cars he was snowboarding in
the street a lot of what he was doing
yeah if you want to take those risks I
suppose but uh you can't play music like
you got to find a band space you can't
play New York City is like the cultural
capital of Earth that's as far as I see
it where would be the cultural capital I
think we are I think we are very sorting
I think he's still number one I don't I
think you're wrong I think New York City
being the cultural capital of the world
yeah I do think that I think it has been
and I don't think that uh there is one
at this point I do think we are
resorting but there isn't a place like
when you get out of college you know or
you want to go do something new I don't
know why you would go to New York at
this point it doesn't have the same kind
of offering as it did the biggest news
companies Broadway yeah I was talking
about a whole bunch
okay okay Wall Street has not been
physically relevant for 20 years their
money is no of course it is but the
money isn't on Wall Street the money is
on the internet there is a guy there was
a guy no one is at Wall Street bro no
one's there okay no one is physically
there they're not there dude they're all
at their house there's a guy yeah
they're all in houses and apartments all
over the country there's a guy who has
crazy hair who's there at the stock
exchange just so that people can take
pictures of them when stock stories
happen because there's nobody there sure
nobody goes there anymore I don't know I
think we might be overlooking the
cultural significance of the greatest
city on Earth but a New York nationalist
so they did Fashion on planet Earth
there's everything listen they did
Fashion Week online right I can see all
the fashion weeks now I don't have to
like wait around for New York's Fashion
Week I can see all of them online even
Trump Tower is in New York City for a
reason but we can there's a Trump Tower
listen I love New York as much as the
next person but I think you're
completely wrong about the cultural
stake at as in the country at this point
maybe not as much as the next person
rent is three to four thousand dollars
rent is very expensive everywhere but
also in New York City it is higher in
New York City but it's the cost of
living this is my pitch to New York City
right now my age group there are twice
as many females and there are males in
New York City more over um among the
males there's a larger homosexual
population than the females so I'm
telling you it is a prime time to be a
young man in New York City yeah if you
want to lick the boot of woke people I
don't like no Buddha pork bro they they
came out with vax mandates and they had
exemptions for themselves that it is a
corrupt city full of full of just
garbage policies these are these are the
people who vote for the for the
Democrats who appoint the police and
then they protest the people they voted
for that's correct it's absolutely
psychotic I guess it is extremely
expensive look New York and LA are
places you go after you've already
established yourself and the biggest
mistake people make I've seen in my
whole life is I'm gonna move to the big
city to succeed and it's like why so you
can be a boot looking intern at a
company it's like the best thing to do
the best thing to do if you want to
create art and you want to do things
that are fun is like get a bunch of your
friends pick a town and I'll move there
together get cheap places you know do
stuff for fun
have a band start a coffee shop enjoy
yourself like relax spend your money
where it counts you don't have to do the
constant hustle that's required in New
York where you only see your friends on
Monday nights when they work hard and
achieve their New York City the world is
yours in New York City you can make it
there you can make it anywhere yeah
thanks Liza Minnelli she's aging out too
yeah well you look at all of the big
YouTubers and all the top personalities
and it's like people start YouTube
channels from their basement in rural
areas now and they they become wealthy
we actually I started in New York City
and left because it was it was stagnant
and it was uh it was a waste of money
come back to him you could do great
things here with the culture
Ambassador now we're doing so much more
having left New York City the fact that
I'm still there is just cultural Tim
cast branch in Brooklyn I don't New York
is a mistake that way and that's why you
know you you see half a million people
flee the city over covid the people who
have remained it's just like you know
you know what New York City is people
chasing after someone else's dream
instead of going and making their own
thing for the record too I don't think
New York is Lefty I think it is liberal
and firmly liberal we did elect a
Democrat we always elect Democrats now
but we did elect mayor Eric Adams who
was a former NYPD officer and everything
relatively well the left hates him and
he's still he's still harsh towards the
left
voting for insane people and complaining
about the inside people who run the city
cultural capital Eric Adams just fired
one of uh was it a lawyer who worked for
the city because she was like you said
Mass would come off kids and then he was
like yeah well I don't care so screw you
like dude these people keep voting for
the same thing and then they protest it
and then vote for the same thing it's
laughably bad New York City is overly
expensive it smells like sour milk
people complain about what they vote for
there was a day 10 years ago it's
spelled like it smelled like syrup oh
yeah it was a really nice day most of
the time it just smells like pot all
right I gotta read more Super chats
that's what we got Hunter Biden's crack
pipe says I believe in pro-choice men
and women both choose to have sex or not
birth control are not then nine months
later mom can choose to keep or give up
for adoption man can choose take
responsibility or not fair for both
sexes
not fair for the child maybe
I mean what's the alternative killing it
yeah I guess so no no there's no perfect
solution we're just tragedy I mean I
think not killing it is the is better
for the child in every capacity
it's weird that like I see these people
and they're like poor kids would be
better off being aborted and it's like
you're telling people you wish they were
like you'd prefer them yeah it's a bad
situation I mean the thing about life is
you know that every life is a is an
opportunity to experience God's grace
and that makes it worth it whether it's
five minutes or 400 years amen
all right let's grab some more Super
chants grafty says Bach grafty has been
greatly supporting chicken City when you
give five dollars on chicken City treats
fall down from the sky egg and the
chickens all run and it's funny when
they like stare at it because they know
food comes from there but they don't
know why or when it's just like it's
like chicken Truman Show having no idea
who's watching these chickens that's
just hilarious chicken chicken party is
fantastic that we love chicken party
all right Democratic detox says y'all
not taking our DeSantis forget about it
can you imagine being in Florida it's
like please don't leave man right right
don't run for president didn't he win by
a small margin against Andrew Gillum or
am I talking about A different race and
he has wasn't Andrew Gillum like a
crackhead in a hotel he came out after
but he lost by five figure I remember
so I mean it's crazy how DeSantis had
this come up really because if he lost
that race by those few votes yeah I know
this would have happened so yeah it's
true when I was in Florida I was talking
to Floridians like I I was talking to
somebody who was like do you think
descendants should be president and they
were like no he should stay here and I
was like all right all right
Nick Nicole Salcido says if a mom shoots
through a wall on purpose to kill her
child she goes to jail what's the
difference with the baby being in utero
it's the same child behind a wall the
child's location shouldn't matter
that's the interesting thing the
weirdest thing about this is like
if uh
a woman is eight months pregnant
and she's like oh no I'm giving you know
birth prematurely and the baby would
survive then what does she do does she
run a planned hair Planned Parenthood
and say quick kill it before it comes
out and it's legal okay like apparently
it is some states yeah and then it's
like Oh No I gave birth oh it's alive
now like is that really the the system
that we're supposed to be living in
that's a horror show but this is what's
happening with unrestricted abortion
there's um the other thing too is there
was for a long time a conversation about
viability and the conversation was about
if the child would be viable outside of
the mother's body and if it was then
abortion was not acceptable
which is around 23 weeks if I'm not
mistaken that's like the viability 50
outside of the womb it keeps getting
lower and lower I think there was like
21 right we got to read only a couple
more um so smash that like button if you
haven't already Jay Richter it's uh Jay
Rickards says Tim is missing the point I
wish everyone would stay in New York and
stop moving to Florida except Libby can
come that's it what about me what I
appreciate it you're gonna go to Florida
and trash and talk about a great New
Year 50 years I'll be in Florida but not
now
GC says they let you know good luck
finding a real estate there oh please GC
says I'm pro-life but I think we should
not trust politicians to create laws
Banning medical procedures or care some
abortions are necessary to save the life
of the mother look up ectopic pregnancy
so this is what I was getting into
earlier
um ectopic pregnancies are classified by
like WebMD Mayo Clinic and even planned
parenthood they're not referred to as
abortions so it's a situation where
you're attempting a procedure or not
just attempting but performing a
procedure that will result in the death
of the The Unborn Child to save the
mother but the intention is not to go in
there
no I mean the other thing too is if you
let an ectopic pregnancy progress it
will kill the child and the mother yes
exactly it doesn't kill everyone
generally it will be a disaster msheba
says keep talking culture but what
happened to the card game that you were
working on we work on it man let's get
it pumped out yes we will and the issue
is uh
we need we need someone who knows how to
make games you know those guys
it wasn't flight testing it was that we
started with a complex game and then it
was substantially too it was it was very
very complex it was it was a turn-based
strategy game we decided to make it to
make a simplified version that was a
party game but we're trying to figure
out
um the game took too long I've played
the simplified version we did this a
couple months ago I thought it was a lot
of fun I did think we could got it to a
goal but I know that I know that a lot
more play testing is required than just
me enjoying it but I feel good about the
thing mostly the point of the game is
just so that there's going to be cards
of people you you know and love so I was
like let's just make a really really
simple really fast game where it's funny
that you're having Alex Jones trying to
get you know uh big red the feminist
canceled off the internet or something
and then you're having you know you know
what we should do sounds fun the cards
we should have the uh as soon as someone
gets banned from the internet we stop
printing their card and so if you had
that card it's extra rare yeah
if you haven't already smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends we are going
to start recording that members only
podcast which will be up at timcast.com
so sign up there if you want to watch it
it'll be up around 11 or so p.m you can
follow the show at timcastirl you can
follow me at timcast uh a lot do you
want to shout anything out hey everybody
I hope you guys enjoyed the show you
could find some of my work is on timcast
um also I have a YouTube channel it's
called barely informed with a lot I do
on the ground reporting I do the same
thing for Tim I'll be responding to
comments if you guys want to go check
that out I have an interesting video
polling Trump supporters if they support
Ukraine or not but again I'll be a lot
on timcast so looking forward to that
uh I'm Libby Emmons I I appreciate the
person who said I could come to Florida
you're allowed now you actually you need
a sponsor to migrate there now I
understand yeah I understand you're
protective of Freedom you know I would
be too
um I'm at the post millennial I'm the
editor-in-chief there I'm on Twitter at
Libby Emmons and coming up actually next
week uh no two weeks I'm gonna be in
Fort Worth at the um better discourse
event which is brought to you by
misinformed
um and it's a great conversation it's a
really fun day and then we all go out
and hang out afterwards it's going to be
in Fort Worth uh it's called it's at
better discourse event.com
um and I think you all should check it
out it's gonna be a lot of fun my name
is Seamus Coughlin I have a YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes we upload
educational cartoons in political satire
mostly satire every Thursday sometimes
on Tuesdays I really think you guys
should go and check it out you're really
going to enjoy it it's going to be your
favorite new YouTube channel hit that
Bell icon I love you uh thank you guys
all very much for tuning in to this
fiery episode of Tim cast IRL this is a
lot of fun I did not say a single word I
just enjoyed listening you guys can find
me on Twitter and minds.com
you can also while you're waiting for
that members only segment at 11 PM check
out chicken City youtube.com chicken
City where you can watch right now live
our chickens just sleeping because it's
it's night but uh in the day the chicken
party meter is available and you can
watch them do chicken stuff and it's
just all the drama when Roberto is
fighting with his son Roberto Jr because
the twins are coming in and you know the
twins are young but Roberto's their dad
and it gets kind of weird with what the
dad is doing to his daughters but I I'm
told in chicken drama it's all
acceptable apparently so you don't want
to miss that but you can also check out
pop culture crisis on YouTube our new
pop culture show hosted by Brett
dasovich so check that out and again go
to timcast.com thanks for hanging out
everybody smash that like button on your
way out and we'll see you all over at
timcast.com I guess